GOOD. WELCOME TO THE MAY
EIGHTEENTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
WE HAVE THE DAY NINE HUNDRED AND
TWELVE BILLS TO CONSIDER THIS
MORNING AS PART OF OUR REGULAR.
ORDERED. WHAT ARE. YEAH WELL ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO. THERE I
AM ADVERTING NUMBERS AGAIN A
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO BILLS TO
CONSIDER THIS MORNING AS PART OF
OUR REGULAR ORDERED HEARING
BEFORE WE BEGAN I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS TO COVER WITH
YOU. FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK A
SIMILAR VOEPEL WHO WILL BE
FILLING IN FOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIS ON THE COMMITTEE TODAY- WE
ALSO AS ALWAYS ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING BY
VISITING THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV
PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED PUBLIC
COMMENT AND MAY BE READ INTO THE
RECORD OR REPRINTED. ALL ARE
ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE HEARING
FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT GOV TODAY'S EVENTS. THE
HEARING ROOM WILL BE OPEN FOR
ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING THE
PUBLIC MAY ALSO PARTICIPATE IN
THE SYRIAN BY PHONE BY CALLING.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN WITH A
CONFIRMATION CODE OF ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO ONE ONE ZERO ZERO.
THAT NUMBER IS ALSO LISTED ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO MONITOR
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR
UPDATES. WE WILL ACCEPT PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY BILL PLACED ON
THE SUSPENSE FILE BY THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. AND FOR WHICH
THE AUTHOR WAY PRESENTATION
BEFORE THE CLOSE OF THE REGULAR
ORDERED HEARING. TESTIMONY ON
THESE BILLS WILL BE LIMITED TO A
STATEMENT OF NAME ORGANIZATION
IF ANY AND POSITION ON THE BILL.
THE COMMITTEE WILL ALLOW NO MORE
THAN FORTY MINUTES OF TESTIMONY
PREFERENCE WILL BE GIVEN TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. AS YOU CAME
INTO THE HEARING ROOM TODAY THE
SERGEANTS DIRECTED YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE RULES
REPUBLICAN ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION. WHICH WERE POSTED
OUTSIDE THE DOOR I ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WERE
IN ATTENDANCE TO BE AWARE OF.
AND OBSERVE THESE RULES. PLEASE
BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. AS WE BEGIN OUR MEETING
I SEE WERE SHORT OF A QUORUM. US
SO WE'RE GOING TO. MOVED TO AS A
SUB COMMITTEE. A TO THE BILLS
THAT ARE UP FOR PRESENTATION
TODAY A MISTER RODRIGUEZ SAYS I
SEE YOU YOU'RE READY TO. RESENT
THIS IS A AB. TWENTY TWO SIXTY.
THERE IS A DO PASS.
HELLO THERE YOU GO OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE. AND
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT A. B.
TWENTY TWO SIXTY WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE CERTAIN PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTED
AFTER JANUARY FIRST 202-220-2020
THREE TO INSTALL AND MAINTAIN
SIX TRAUMA KITS ON THEIR
PREMISES IN ORDER TO TREAT
PEOPLE IN NEED OF EMERGENCY CARE
DURING A DRAMATIC EMERGENCY
EVENT. IN RESPONSE TO THE TRAGIC
MASS SHOOTING AT SET A MENTERI
SCHOOL A GROUP OF DOCTORS
CONVENE A PANEL OF NATIONAL
EXPERTS FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
TRICKS TO CREATE IMPROVED
RESPONSE SYSTEM DIRECTED
PRIMARILY AT THE CONTROL OF LIFE
THREATENING BLOOD LOSS. IN THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS THE GROUP OF
EXPERTS CONCLUDED THAT
BYSTANDERS IMMEDIATELY RESPONDED
SHOULD BE TRAINED AND EMPOWERED
TO STOP HEMORRHAGE IN ORDER TO
SAVE LIVES THESE EXPERTS ALSO
RECOMMEND A TRAUMA KITS BE
PLACED IN PUBLIC PLACES SUCH AS
SHOPPING MALLS SCHOOLS SUPPORT
VENUES TRANSPORTATION CENTERS
EXCEPT ROSE RIGHT NEXT TO A
EDIE'S. RECOGNIZING THE
DIFFICULTY TO MAINTAIN DIRECT
PRESSURE THEY ALSO RECOMMENDED
THE USE OF TOURNIQUETS CONTROL
SEVERE BLEEDING WITH MASS
CASUALTY EVENTS BECOMING MORE
COMMON IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA LAUNCHED STOP
THE BLEED CAMPAIGN TO ENCOURAGE
BYSTANDERS TO BECOME TRAINED AND
EMPOWERED TO TAKE LIFESAVING
ACTION WHILE EMS PERSONNEL ARE
IN ROUTE. ACCORDING TO THE GUN
VIOLENCE ARCHIVE OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS SEEN OVER TWO HUNDRED
MASS SHOOTINGS THIS YEAR ALONE.
AT LEAST FOUR OF THESE MASS
SHOOTINGS HAVE HAPPENED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES OF SACRAMENTO
INGLEWOOD ALAN OF M. LAGUNA
WOODS. DURING THESE TRAGIC
EVENTS A PERSON SUFFERING FROM
SEVERE BLOOD LOSS CAN DIE WITHIN
FIVE MINUTES SO EVERY SECOND
TRULY COUNTS. THAT IS WHY SOME
POINT ENSURE OUR MEDIA
RESPONDERS OF THE STRUCTURES AND
INCRIMINATED THIS THE SAVE TO
RENDER EMERGENCY CARE. AT THE
SCENE OF AN EMERGENCY. WITH ME
TO PROVIDE IN PERSON TESTIMONY
OUR DOCTOR DOCTOR AMY LIE PART A
TRAUMA SURGEON WITH THE UC SAN
DIEGO. HEALTH OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF SURGEONS. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU TO HOLDEN AND
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FOR
THE PRIVILEGE OF ADDRESSING YOU
THIS MORNING I AM DOCTOR ANY
LEOPARD A DOUBLE BOARD CERTIFIED
TRAUMA SURGEON AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO UCSD IS
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF SURGEONS
VERIFIED LEVEL ONE TRAUMA
CENTER. I REPRESENT THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF SURGEONS THE THREE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF SURGEONS A
CONSENSUS COALITION OF NATIONAL
AND STATE HEALTH AND FIRST
RESPONDER GROUPS AND MYSELF IT
IS NATIONAL STOP THE BLEED MONTH
AND FRIDAY IS NATIONAL STOP THE
BLEED DAY. LIFE THREATENING
BLEEDING CAN OCCUR ANYWHERE. AT
HOME THE WORK PLACE IN PUBLIC
PLACES. TRAFFIC CRASHES IT CAN
BE ACCIDENTAL INTENTIONAL FROM
NATURAL DISASTER. NATURAL
DISASTER AND YES MASS SHOOTING
EVENTS. MILITARY INJURY
TREATMENT HAS TAUGHT US LESSONS
THAT CAN BE APPLIED TO TRUST US
CIVILIAN TRAUMA SITUATIONS.
INCLUDING THAT EARLY CONTROL OF
BLEEDING SAVES LIVES AND LIMBS.
CLEAN TREATMENT CAN AND IS
TAUGHT TO THE CIVILIAN PUBLIC.
AFTER THE NEWTOWN SCHOOL
SHOOTING DOCTOR LEN WORTH JACOBS
A FELLOW TAUMA SURGEON. BROUGHT
TOGETHER SURGEONS FIRST
RESPONDERS AND MILITARY AS A
GROUP KNOWN AS THE HARTFORD
CONSENSUS. FROM THAT GROUP THE
STOP THE BLEED GRAHAM WAS
DEVELOPED BY THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF SURGEONS AND IS NOW
CO SPONSORED BY THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY. MAJOR NATIONAL MEDICAL
AND FIRST RESPONDER
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE ENDORSED ITS
USE A CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
SUPPORT HAS BEEN DEVELOPED FOR
AB TWO TWO SIX ZERO. THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTY
ASSOCIATION HAS PREVIOUSLY ALSO
STATE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. THE
PROGRAM HAS EVEN BEEN TAKEN BACK
TO THE WAR ZONES IN THE UKRAINE
BY MY FELLOW TRAUMA SURGEON DR
ROBERT LAMM TO TRAIN CIVILIANS
THERE. THE SITUATION OF
UNTHINKABLE CIVILIAN TRAUMA AND
LOSS. RECENT EVENTS FROM
SACRAMENTO HERE TO BUFFALO AND
BACK TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAVE
SHOWN US WHAT HARM CAN BE DONE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND THAT WE
MUST BE PREPARED TO ACT. COST IS
NOMINAL EACH KISS EACH KIT SUCH
AS THIS. COST APPROX FORTY
DOLLARS EVEN WITH INCREASED
COSTS. ARE IN THE MARKET TODAY
THAT'S LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS FOR ALL SIX KIDS
REQUIRED WITHIN THE BILL. THAT'S
LESS THAN THE FIFTY TO ME THAT'S
LESS THAN 15% OF WHAT ONE EIGHTY
THE INSTALLATION COSTS. THERE
ARE NO EXPIRATION DATES ON THIS
EQUIPMENT GOD'S GLOVES MASH
SHEARS AND TOURNIQUETS. IT
INSTALLATION COSTS ARE ALSO FREE
AS THE KIDS CAN BE STORED IN
ALREADY- REQUIRED INSTALLED
EIGHTY CONTAINERS. AND THEY
ALREADY ARE IN MANY PLACES SUCH
AS THE SAN DIEGO AND LA
AIRPORTS. EDUCATION TO THE
PUBLIC IS WIDESPREAD AND FREE
AND AVAILABLE ONLINE EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW EXAMS OF FOLKS
AND PUBLIC ORGANIZATIONS AND
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS FROM
LIABILITY. TOURNIQUETS HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO IMPROVE. OF LIVES SAVED
AND REDUCE BLOOD TRANSFUSION AND
NO HARM HAS BEEN SEEN FROM
TOURNIQUET USE BY THE PUBLIC. A
TRAUMA KIT CAN ALLOW PATIENTS
SURIVE TRANSPORT TO A TRAUMA
CENTER BUT THEY DON'T BLEED TO
DEATH ON THE SCENE PLEASE VOTE
YES ON A. B. TWO TWO SIX ZERO
FOR BLEEDING CONTROL KITS TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE WHERE THEY ARE
NEEDED. IN THE COMMUNITY TO SAVE
LIVES AND TO STOP THE BLEED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT ESTABLISH A CORE. HOLDEN
HERE BIGELOW. BRIAN CALDERON
VIDEO VOEPEL. DAVIES MIKE FONG
VINCE FONG. GABRIEL EDUARDO
GARCIA LEVINE. QUOTE I'M HERE
ROBERT RIVAS. WEBER WILSON.
DOLLY SORRY THANK YOU FORMAS
ESTABLISHED WILL TURN TO THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM OR
ANY COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. THE
NINE WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES PHONE OPERATOR MOVES AVAIL
. IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
OF PHONE OPERATOR WE'RE LOOKING
FOR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY TWO SIXTY. YOU ARE PART
OF AB TWENTY SIX THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THE END OF THEIR
OWN. SENATE THAT OWNING YOU.
THANK YOU WILL TURN THE HEARING
ROOM ANY OPPOSITION THE TWENTY
TO SIXTY. THEY NINE PHONE
OPERATOR. OPPOSITION. TWENTY TWO
SIXTY. IF YOU ARE NOT. ONE AND
THEN. I DON'T WANT YOU THEY WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SEEING NO COMMENTS OF THIS BILL
IS DUE PASS AND IT'S OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO OR NOT
VOTING- AND VOEPEL IN FONG. THE
RESULT. WITH THAT- MEMBERS AS OF
MONDAY WE CELEBRATED EMS WEEK I
THINK IT'S A IT'S AN HONOR TO
FORGET YOUR SUPPORT AS YOU SEE
THESE KIDS HERE REALLY TRULY
SAVE LIVES ARE SPEC AS RIVALS
THANK YOU. THOSE OUT. AGAIN
WITH- REPUBLICANS NOT I'M SORRY. REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING APPEL
AND VINCE FONG. GOOD YES. BYE
BYE THANK. OKAY- THE PHARMACIST. MR FONG HAS TO. THE EXCUSE TO
A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING SO
WE'LL GIVE HIM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AND THEY WILL MOVE IN
THE ORDER OF THOSE- MEMBERS
WHO'VE COME INTO THE HEARING
ROOM. I THANK YOU. I THINK WAS
CHAIR MEMBERS I APPRECIATE AT
THE LATITUDE ASSEMBLY BILL. A
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY EIGHT IS AN
IMMEDIATE SOLUTION TO REMOVE
CONGESTION AT THE PORTS AND
IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S FREIGHT
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THE BILL ALLOWS TEMPORARY USE
PERMITS TO MOVE FORWARD SO THAT
DEVELOPERS CAN IMMEDIATELY
COMMENCE SHORT TERM FREIGHT
TRANSPORTATION USES I'M JOINED
BY JASON SPELLS OR ON BEHALF OF
THE PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION. EXACTLY THAT'S WHEN
ABOUT OKAY. WITH READINGS ON HIS
NECK. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERS AT JASON SHELTER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION APPIUM
ASSAYS MEMBERS ARE THE OCEAN
CARRIERS AND MARINE TERMINAL
OPERATORS OPERATING A
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SEAPORTS I
YOU'RE ALL AWARE OF THE ONGOING
PUBLIC SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS IN
THE IMPACTS OF CAN BE FELT
ACROSS LEGISLATIVE DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA APENAS AND CAP OF
COSPONSORED A PACKAGE OF BILLS
DESIGNED TO RESPOND TO THIS
PLEDGING CRISIS IN VARIOUS WAYS
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS.
BEFORE CLOSELY WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE ON LANGUAGE
AND WE ARE DR- TODAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU WILL TURN TO
SUPPORT IN THE HEARING ROOM
SCENE NINE PHONE OPERATOR WE
ARE. LOOKING FOR SUPPORT.
COMMENTS ON TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS THE ONE THAT THEN
ZERO. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THEY WILL
TURN TO THE HEARING ROOM
OPPOSITION. SAY NONE OPERATOR
OPPOSITION ON. TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NO ONE THANK YOU.
VERY VERY BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SAY NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR YOUR TIME. ALLOW ME TO
PRESENT AB SEVENTY NINE ZERO
FOUR. WITH THAT IN THE MOVIE-
LONG SCHEDULE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE OKAY YOU HAVE A
WITNESS I DO NOT DENY OKAY I
WILL LOOK TO THE HEARING ROOM. A
SUPPORT. OWNER OPERATOR SUPPORT
ON AB SEVENTEEN OH FOUR. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. SEVENTEEN
OH FOUR TO SIX. SEVENTEEN OH
FOUR. SEVENTEEN OH FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND WE HAVE
ONE IN Q. NINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- LICENSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COULD BE AFTER
MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE LIKE TO
TAKE A SIMILAR CHEN FOR
CHAMPIONS BILL FOR US. AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. M.
LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND NO RESPONSE THERE
AREN'T THERE'S NOBODY ELSE LEFT
THANK YOU HEY OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. OPPOSITION ONLINE. IF YOU ARE NOT THE VISION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. MAN
NO ONE IS IN Q. A TURN TO THE
COMMITTEE SYRIAN- COMMENTS THE
BILLS OUT A RECALL THANK YOU
MISTER WITH YOUR TIME. THIS
BONTA. DO YOU HAVE- THREE BILLS
UP TODAY. DELAYED WITH- TWENTY
THREE NINETEEN. YOU. AND THAT IS
A DO PASS. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE
NINETEEN IS A BILL. IS THE
DISTRICT BILL SEEKING A SIMPLE
FIX WITHIN A COMPLICATED ISSUE
AREA THE SURPLUS LAND ACT AB
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN WOULD
PROVIDE A NARROW EXEMPTION TO
THE SURPLUS LANDS ACTS FOR THE
FORMAL ALLEN FORMER ALAMEDA
NAVAL AIR STATION AND IN DOING
SO PROVIDE CLARITY AND A PATH
FORWARD. FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA HCD ANTICIPATES
MINOR AND ABSORB ALL COSTS.
THANK YOU AND AS WITNESSES WITH
ME TODAY I HAVE ON THE PHONE
LISA MAXWELL COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR FOR THE
CITY INTO AN IN PERSON WAS ANNA
ELLIOTT BUT WITH CLEAR ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
FOR TECHNIQUE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. OKAY SO
WILL TURN TO YOU FOR TECHNICAL
CASH QUESTIONS FOR BOTH FROM
BOTH. I WOULDN'T WISH IT WE CAN
DO THAT YES OKAY YOU CAN TURN TO
TECH YES BUT ARE THEY WILL LOOK
TO ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO. THE OTHER
COMMENTS AND SUPPORT. TWENTY
THREE NINETEEN A NON PHONE
OPERATOR SUPPORT ON TWENTY THREE
NINETEEN. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF TWENTY THREE NINETEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND AT THIS
TIME THERE IS NO ONE IN Q.
HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION.
THE TERM MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OR
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION. C. NINE
PHONE OPERATOR OPPOSITION ON
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN. WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY THREE
NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO AND AT THIS TIME THERE
ISN'T ONE MOMENT PLEASE BE JUST
A MOMENT ONE PERSON DID JUST
QUEUE UP. AND THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT OF Q. THERE'S NO
ONE IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS OUT ON THE B.
ROLL CALL DOLLY NOT VOTING.
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR MOVE THE
BILL. BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR WILL ACCOMPLISH
TWO GOALS FIRST IT WILL INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IN THE VENTURE THAT A CHARTER
SCHOOL CLOSES AND SECONDLY THE
BILL CLOSES THE LOOPHOLE AND HOW
CHARTER SCHOOLS SPEND
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS
IF A CHARTER SCHOOL CLOSES WE
MUST ENSURE THAT OUR STATE
INVESTMENT TO CONTINUE TO BE
HELD BY THE PUBLIC FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF STUDENTS. I
ENSURING THAT PUBLIC AGENCIES IN
PARTICULAR RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS
THIS BILL HAS MINOR AND OBSERVE
BECAUSE AND AMENDMENTS WOULD
AUTHORIZE BUT NOT REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FINANCE
AUTHORITY THE LEVY ANY
APPLICATION FEES FOR COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROCESSING
APPLICATIONS THE DEFRAY ANY
ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR. THE AGING
WE THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS
AROUND THE DEED RESTRICTION AND
OTHERS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED CONVERSATION AROUND
HOW BEST TO PRESERVE PUBLIC
GOVERNANCE FOR PUBLICLY FUNDED
PROPERTIES HERE WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE CASTING MONTINI ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
KATHLEEN MANZINI HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD PREVENT
TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT WAS MEANT
FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION FROM BEING
USED BY PRIVATECORPORATIONS TO
AMASS REAL ESTATE WITHOUT THE
OVERSIGHT TYPICALLY REQUIRED FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOL FACILITY
ACQUISITION- IT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL COMMONSENSE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT CLOSE. AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR HAS
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE COSTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FINANCE
AUTHORITY AND MAY ALSO BRING
REVENUE TO THE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM. SHOULD A
CHARTER COMPANY SELL OR LEASE
THE RELATED PARTY FACILITY.
ADDITIONALLY AMENDMENTS THE BILL
AUTHORIZED BUT NOT REQUIRED YES
A FATAL LEVY AN APPLICATION FEE
FOR RELATED PARTY APPLICANTS TO
CONDUCT NECESSARY APPLICATION
REVIEW AND OVERSIGHT. BY DESIGN
THIS BILL WILL SAFEGUARD
TAXPAYER INVESTMENTS AND
PUBLICLY FUNDED PROPERTIES AND
ENSURE THAT THESE GRANT FUNDS
ALLOCATED BY THE STATE ARE USED
FOR THEIR INTENDED PURPOSE. ALL
NOTE THAT WENT HURDLES LEVY
RELATED PARTY AGREEMENTS TO
RECEIVE SB SEVEN FORTY GRAND
DOLLARS. THEY CAN USE THOSE
DOLLARS TO PAY OFF ALONE WITHOUT
THE CONDITIONS PLACED ON CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES ACQUIRED
THROUGH THE EXISTING STATE BONDS
PROGRAM. FOR EXAMPLE THESE
FACILITIES DO NOT NEED TO MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR PUBLIC
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION AND
RETROFITTING. THEIR FUNDING IS
NOT POPPED THE SCHOOL'S
FINANCIAL SOUNDNESS IS NOT VALID
THERE'S NO PROCESS OUTLINED IN
LAW FOR USE OF THE FACILITY IF
IT'S NO LONGER NEEDED BY THE
CHARTER SCHOOL. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY AFTER ABOUT. THANK
YOU- SUPPORT FROM. ANYONE FROM
IN THE HEARING ROOM. OWNER
OPERATOR WILL TURN TO SUPPORT
FOR TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR. ON
THE PHONE LINE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS. ONE THEN.
ZERO AND AT THIS TIME THERE IS
NO ONE IN Q. AND BACK TO THE
HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR. AN
ORGANIZATION AND HIS MAKE YOU
MISTER CHAIR ALICE KESSLER AT
GREENBERG TRAURIG I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
WE HAVE IN OPPOSE POSITION ON
THE BILL. WE ARE HEARING FROM
CHARTER SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THIS COULD HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON A PROGRAM
THAT HAS REALLY BEEN SUCCESSFUL
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND OUR HIGHEST
NEEDS STUDENTS- BUT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF COMMITTEE I'LL FOCUS
ON A FEW FISCAL POINTS. FIRST WE
HAVE YOU AS A WITNESS ON THIS OF
THE START UP BUTTON NO BUT
BUILT. NOT EAGER TAKE ANOTHER
THIRTY WOULD BE OKAY IF I FINISH
UP A COUPLE OF POINTS ONE. WE
WERE DISPUTE THAT CASF A WOULD
NOT HAVE ANY COSTS WE DON'T
DON'T AGREE THAT THIS WOULD BE
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE. THERE ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE IN OVERSIGHT
COSTS POTENTIAL APPEALS-
SECONDLY I BELIEVE THERE'S AN
AUDIT ON UNDER WAY THAT MS BONTA
HAS REQUESTED AND WE THINK THIS
IS A- WE ARE WE THINK THAT'S
APPROPRIATE AND WE WOULD SUPPORT
THAT- BUT AT THIS TIME WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND OPPOSITION TO
THE STORE AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR JUST TO CLARIFY I'M
CASEY O'CONNOR FROM THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE WE DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL. BUT
SINCE IS A VESSEL COMMITTEE WE
WANTED TO NOTE THAT THIS IS NOT
MINOR OBSERVABLE TO US. OUR
STAFF NOTED IT WOULD COST THEM
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF NEW STAFF WE
NEED THREE NEW FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES WOULD ALSO NEED
OUTSIDE CONSULTANTS TO THE
VERIFYING OF THE LEANS IN LEASE
AGREEMENTS. WHICH WE NEED
ANOTHER 1-002-200-1000 FOR
ANNUALLY AN ON GOING. AND AGAIN
WE DO WELCOME THE AUDIT AND WE
RESPECT THE AUTHOR AND WE'RE NOT
OPPOSING BUT WE DO HAVE COSTS TO
THIS IS WHEN I WENT THAT. THANKS
THANK YOU. A SENIOR NO. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION. WE'LL
TURN TO THE PHONE LINES PHONE
OPERATOR OPPOSITION ON. TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR. IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
WE HAVE LINE AT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS
BOB NAYLOR REPRESENTING FEELS
THAT IN COMPANY OWNED BY HOWARD
AHMANSON JUNIOR AND ORANGE
COUNTY. LET THE POST- STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. NINE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SEVENTY TWO. GOOD MORNING SURE
HOLDEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MYRA SALAZAR I AM DIRECTOR OF
ADVOCACY AT ALLIANCE COLLEGE
READY PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I
OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR. NINE SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SIXTY NINE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR MY
NAME IS CASEY ANGEL I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR GROWTH
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL. TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR. MY NUMBER
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING WITH
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS HOW YOUR DAY IS WITHOUT
THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE MOST
DEFINITELY OPPOSE THE A BILL.
THIS BILL WOULD BE DEVASTATING
TO THE- 89% PRE REDUCE LATINO
STUDENTS THAT WE SERVE THE BILL-
WILL BE EXISTENTIAL TOO MANY
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE. NINE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SEVENTY FIVE. MY NAME IS HILARY
HARMON I SERVICE CHIEF GROWTH
OFFICER. COOL NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR AND THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT WOULD HAVE ON
OUR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES AND
THE COMMUNITIES CARE. THANK
YOUNG. LINE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THE SEVENTY THREE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ATTY
BECAUSE MINE I AM THE BUSINESS
FINANCE MANAGER AT ALBANY
INTERNATIONAL PRESS HIGH SCHOOL
AND I STRONG AND CLOSE THE BILL
. NINE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIFTY TWO. OKAY HI
RICHARDSON CEO OF LIGHTHOUSE
COMMUNITY PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND-
THE SPONSORS DISTRICT IN EAST
OAKLAND- THIS BILL HAS SOME- IS
GONNA HAVE MAJOR RACIALLY
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT IN THIS
IS A BILL THAT WOULD
DRAMATICALLY SORRY NAME
ORGANIZATION ON COLD AND-
POSITIONS ALL WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THE
SHARES IN CEO OF WHITE HOUSE
COMMITTEE PUBLIC SCHOOLS I'M
WORRIED ABOUT THE RACIALLY
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT HAVE IN
EAST OAKLAND THANK YOU PHONE
OPERATOR. NEXT SPEAKER. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE LEFT
THANK YOU. I MISS BONTA WILL
TURN BACK TO THIS AS A DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS. OF RECOMMENDED
. THANK I HAVE SOME LATER FOR A
MAN ON BILL WHICH WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD ON THE POLICY SIDE- AND
I DO BELIEVE THAT YOUR ANALYSIS
HAS A- MINOR AN OBSERVABLE COSTS
ALTHOUGH WE ARE OPEN TO.
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE TO ENSURE
THAT AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
WE CAN ACCOUNT FOR ANY COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS AND ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY
PUT IN. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR
BE FOR THERE TO BE REVENUE
GENERATING OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH
AT RECOVERY OF APPLICATION FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS- IN IN THE
LEGISLATION AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR IBOOK.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO- MOVE THE
VOTE TO LITTLE BIT LATER IN THE
MEETING IF THAT'S OKAY- LET A
FEW MORE MEMBERS COMMAND AND
THEN WE WILL TAKE YOUR BILL BACK
UP FOR A VOTE. I WILL TAKE UP AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY IS YOUR NEXT
BILL AS A TO PASS. THANK YOU. AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY ESTABLISHES A
PILOT PROGRAM FOR ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA. COUNTIES AND THE
CITIES WITHIN THOSE COUNTIES TO
TURN BLIGHTED PROPERTIES INTO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS. AND IN THE PROCESS
REDUCES CRIME AND COST A LOT
GOVERNMENTS. PERFECT
NEIGHBORHOODS. AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY. THIS BY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IDENTIFY THEIR
BLIGHTED PROPERTIES AND DEVELOP
A PLAN IN CONJUNCTION WITH
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS LOCAL
COMMUNITY FOUNDATIONS. AND LOCAL
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
REVITALIZES PROPERTIES AND
RETURN THEM TO COMMUNITY HANDS.
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTIES LOCAL
COSTS FALL BELOW THE SUSPENSE
THRESHOLD. THANK YOU AND AS A
WITNESS WITH ME ON THE PHONE I
HAVE NIKKI BEASLEY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE RICHMOND
NEIGHBORHOOD. A COMMUNITY
NEIGHBORHOOD HOUSING SERVICES
VERY GOOD WILL TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES NOW TO HEAR YOUR YOUR MAIN
WITNESS. NIKKI BEASLEY. ON
OPERATOR. NIKKI BEASLEY AS
WITNESS. IN SUPPORT WARNING IN
THE MORNING I THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY COMMITTEE AS THE
LEAD CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL WE
WANT TO REITERATE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS FOR
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS AT THE
SAME TIME ADDRESSING COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN
DISENFRANCHISED AND- ADDRESSING
THE WEALTH STRIPPING IN
COMMUNITIES THAT WE CARE ABOUT
BY BRINGING ON DOMBEY. DORMANT
BLIGHTED PROPERTIES BACK INTO
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT PLACING AN
INDIVIDUAL IT ALSO PROVIDES A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT- COMPONENT
I FIFTEEN EMERGING DEVELOPERS
GET INTO THE DEVELOPMENT MARKET
AT A SCALABLE PROJECT THAT IS
MANAGEABLE. REVENUES BACK INTO
MUNICIPALITIES AND MANY OF THESE
PROPERTIES AT COLD ENFORCEMENT
NIGHTMARES ON AND WE ARE ALSO
LOOKING TO CREATE HOUSING FOR
ALL BY LEVERAGING DOLLARS THAT
WILL NOT BE ANY DIRECT
COMPETITION TO THE RENTAL MARKET
THANK YOU. WE MOVED AND SECONDED. WE WILL TURN TO. ACTUALLY WILL
STAY ONLINE AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
LEND THEIR SUPPORT TO AB. TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION OF SUPPORT. I HAVE COME
FROM THE PHONE LINES YES PLEASE
. OH SORRY BUT WE HAVE NOBODY IN
Q. WELL IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
DO HAVE ONE EIGHTY SIX ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. I EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME YES. HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER APPLE REYES I APOLOGIZE
THEY DIDN'T UNDERSTAND HOW THE
SYSTEM WORKS I WAS TRYING TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION AB ON
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR- BUT I
WAS NOT ABLE TO- FIGURE OUT THE
QUEUE SYSTEM SO IF YOU CAN NOTE
THAT I'D APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU. DEMOCRATS ALRIGHT I AM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF PACIFIC
CHARTER SCHOOL DEVELOPMENT IN
THE BAY AREA REGION BUT CALLING
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF. THANK YOU.
M. LINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN EIGHTY EIGHT. YOUR
BROWSER CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CARE CALIFORNIA WE ARE UNABLE TO
SPEAK- FOUR TWO FOUR EIGHT FOUR
AND WE'RE JUST CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. OKAY PHONE OPERATOR
WERE ONLY TAKING TESTIMONY AT
THIS TIME FOR TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
. AND WE WILL ALSO ALLOW FOR
OPPOSITION SO IT'S SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES
WILL ENTERTAIN. YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION FOR TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN
Q. THERE ANYONE IN HEARING ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. THEY NINE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
WE'RE OUT ON A ROLL CALL. IF
REVELERS. THIS RIVAS. MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER MEMBERS I'M AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY FOUR WOULD REQUIRE NON
RECHARGEABLE ALL IN ONE CANNABIS
VAPES TO BE PROPERLY LABELED AS
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND NOT MARKETED
AS DISPOSABLE THIS BILL SHOULD
HAVE MINIMAL AND ABSORB
OBSERVABLE COSTS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAVAL THANK
YOU IS THERE SUPPORT. IN THE
HEARING ROOM. JEREMIAH MARC
PRAYER ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC
SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE. WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINE SUPPORT
A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR. YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND THERE IS NO ONE
IN Q. A HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION. THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS GRAHAM
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE PARENT
COMPANY THE LARGEST CANNABIS
COMPANY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THE
MESSAGE BUT WE OPPOSE THE
DELIVERY METHOD METHOD IN THIS
BILL WHAT FOR TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE PHONE LINE THE
PHONE OPERATOR OPPOSITION
EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR. IF YOU'RE
IN A POSITION OF EIGHTEEN NINETY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE OF THEM
ZERO. AT THIS TIME NO ONE IS IN
Q. IT WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SEEING NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS THIS IS A DO PASS IT'S
OUT ON A ROLL CALL WITH VINCE
FONG NOT VOTING. THANK YOU.
MISTER GIBSON. AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY NINE TWENTY THREE FIFTY
NINE THE PASS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ARE
VERY BRIEFLY THANK YOU ALLOW
THEM TO. COMPTON COLLEGE IN THE
QUÉ COMPTON COMMUNITY THANK THIS
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOW THIS BILL TO
BE HEARD TODAY RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU ARE YOU HAVE A
WITNESS ONLINE. YES I WOULDN'T
ON THE LINE MISTER BROWN. PHONE
OPERATOR I WILL TAKE A TESTIMONY
FROM TRISTEN BROWN. IN SUPPORT
BOARDING HERE TO MONITOR MEMBERS
TRICKING BROWN LOOKS YOU HAVE TO
UNION OF EDUCATORS AND QUALIFIED
PROFESSIONALS WE REPRESENT THE
HARDWORKING CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
OF THE COMPANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT TO A TWO THOUSAND FOUR-
UNFORTUNATELY LOST THEIR RIGHT
TO BE VOTED IN TO BE AMERICA
SISTER CAN HAVE A PERSONAL
COMMISSION HELP THEM WITH ANY OF
THE- HR AND OTHER PERSONNEL
ISSUES THAT MIGHT ARISE AT THE
COLLEGE. IT'S A VITALLY
IMPORTANT COMPONENT IN AMERICA
STRICTLY BE ABLE TO HAVE
REPRESENTATION THEIR WORK OUT
ISSUES- WITH A REPRESENTATION
FROM LABOR FOR MANAGEMENT AND
THEN THE THIRD NEUTRAL PARTY TO
HELP DECIDE ON POLICY MATTERS AT
THAT- CONCERNED PERSONNEL- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES THAT THE
COLLEGES DEBASING AND ARE
OVERCOMING- IN FACT THAT IT
LOOKS LIKE. THEY MAY BE ABLE TO
PAY DOWN THEIR DEBTS EVEN.
CREATED WOULD PROBABLY APPLAUD
THE WORK HAS BEEN DONE BUT CURRY
THERE TO. THE COLLEGE- THIS WILL
WILL PROVIDE A TIME LINE FOR
THEM TO HAVE THEIR RIGHTS
RESTORED AS THOSE. OBLIGATIONS
ARE PAID. AND BEGIN TO HAVE
THEM. RETRAIN THEMSELVES ON
UTILIZING- THE MERIT SYSTEM AND
THE PERSONNEL- COMMISSION SO
THAT BY THE TIME THEY REACHED.
OUT RESTORE FULL GOVERNANCE ARE
ABLE TO UTILIZE THOSE RIGHTS
PROPERLY SO WE ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OWNER
OPERATOR WILL TAKE ONLINE
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY THREE
FIFTY NINE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY THREE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO
ONE IN Q. AND CAN YOU ALSO JUST
ASK FOR SUPPORT. RETAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME THERE IS
NO ONE IN Q. AND THE HEARING
ROOM OPPOSITION. C. NINE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO. COMMITTEE NO
QUESTIONS COMMENTS THIS IS ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DR WOULD. ENJOYS A DO PASS.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE TWENTY TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- NUMBERS- WELL
FARMS IN CALIFORNIA DESTROYED
APPROXIMATELY. FIFTY THOUSAND
HOMES. I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY.
HERE'S TO BEYONCE IS A BETTER MR
THANK YOU SORRY- WHAT FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE DESTROYED
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THOUSAND
HOMES AS WELL AS COUNTLESS OTHER
STRUCTURES INCLUDING GOVERNMENT
BUILDINGS AND SCHOOLS THAT
EXISTS TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
THE COMMUNITY. VERY DIFFICULT TO
REBUILD DEVASTATED COMMUNITIES
WHEN YOU SERVICES ARE DISPLACED
IN A COMMUNITY. AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY TWO ADDRESSES ITS KEY
THIS ISSUE BY FOCUSING ON
STANDARDS THAT INCREASE FIRE
SAFETY FOR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILDINGS LOCATED
IN HIGH RISK ZONES. BY SHARING
THESE BUILDINGS HAVE A BETTER
CHANCE REMAINING IN PLACE AFTER
A CATASTROPHIC FIRE WE MINIMIZE
ONE OF THE HURDLES ENCOUNTERED
WE COMMUNITIES MAKING DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW AND WHERE TO REBUILD.
I DON'T BELIEVE I HAVE WE HAVE A
WITNESS WHO MIGHT BE HEARD IS.
OR BUT WE MIGHT NOT I THINK I
GOT UP HERE FASTER THAN AN THAT
WAS EXPECTED SO- WITHOUT AYE
ASPIRIN AYE. VERY GOOD. ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT.
SAY NONE PHONE OPERATOR SUPPORT. FOR TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO.
YOUR IN SUPPORT FOR TWENTY THREE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE THE LINE NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN THE LINE
NINETY NINE. LINE NINETY NINE.
GARY MORNING SHAREHOLDERS AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NOBODY SHOULD
BOTHER WITH SPCS AND- I'M
CALLING HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN NO-
WE ARE APPRECIATE WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT ON I'M
SORRY. THE BILL THAT WE'RE
HEARING TESTIMONY ON IS. TWENTY
THREE TWENTY TWO. IT WAS. THREE
TWENTY SO PHONE OPERATOR THERE'S
NO ONE LEFT THANK YOU OKAY. I
WILL TAKE OPPOSITION. THE.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO. ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINES IN OPPOSITION
FOR TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND
THERE IS NO ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE WE HAVE A
PROMOTION TO SUPPORT- IT'S A DO
PASS OF FROM DOCTOR QUIRK WE
NEED A SECOND. THANK YOU FOR
MISS CARILLO. I KNOW OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS ON A ROLL
CALL. VERY MUCH.
MISTER BRIAN.
THIS IS THE EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT
TO PASS. MORE MATURE AND MEMBERS
A. B. EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT-
REQUIRES THE PURPOSE OF DRAWING
DISTRICT LINES FIRST THE STATE
LEGISLATOR CONGRESSMAN BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION THAT EACH
INCARCERATED PERSON IN THE STATE
BE DEEMED A RESIDENT OF THE
PERSON'S LAST KNOWN PLACE OF
ADDRESS THIS BILL IS CONSISTENT
WITH STATE LAW GOVERNING LOCAL
REDISTRICTING AND WITH ACTIONS
TAKEN BY THE CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION WHEN IT
DREW NEW LINES JUST LAST YEAR.
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
THERE ARE NO COST OF THIS BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU HAVE A WITNESS ON WHY
NOT OKAY WILL RETURN TO THE
HEARING ROOM ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT. SAYING
NONE. OF PHONE OPERATOR WILL
TAKE A SUPPORT ON FOURTEEN I'M
SORRY EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT BRIAN
. WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE NOW
THEN THERE ARE ALL. AT THIS TIME
THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. A PHONE
OPERATOR CAN YOU CHECK TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE TO. COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTEEN FORTY
EIGHT. ONLINE IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE BOTTOM LINE
FOR EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE. BUTTON ZERO. IN THE
AND BE A WITNESS FOR A- MEASURE
I DO HAVE A WITNESS TO TESTIFY
LEISURE FERNANDES MY APOLOGIES.
OKAY NO PROBLEM- SO. GO FORWARD
OF WILL HEAR THE- YOUR WITNESS
TESTIMONY NOW. SHE'S ONLINE LISA
FERNANDES. YES I AM IT CAN YOU
HEAR ME SIR CAN. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR KAREN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
NINETY SEVEN MATHIS AND MANDATE
COMMISSIONER ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TESTIFIED TODAY ABOUT IMPORTANT
LEGISLATIVE CHANGE BEFORE THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THE
POLICY CHANGES INCLUDING EIGHTY
EIGHTY FORTY EIGHT RELATING
SPECIFICALLY INCARCERATED PERSON
CONTAIN MINIMAL ANY FISCAL
IMPACT IT CALIFORNIA THEREFORE
THE CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION SUPPORT
FIFTEEN. I WOULD BE HAPPY. TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND I THINK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. A YOU.
WELCOME BACK TO THE HEARING
ROOM- FOR OPPOSITION. OWNER
OPEATOR WILL TAKE OPPOSITION ON
EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT. IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION FOR EIGHTEEN FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE NOT DONE
THERE ALL. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
C. NINE S. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND THE AUTHOR IF YOU CAN HELP
EXPLAIN- AT AS THIS BILL IS
PRESENTED- HAVING THE PRISONERS
COUNTY WHERE THEY PREVIOUSLY
RESIDED WHICH THEY DON'T RESIDE
NOW THEY'RE ACTUALLY RESIDE AND
THEY'RE COUNTED PROPERLY UNDER
THE US CENSUS BUREAU IN THE
PLACE THEY RESIDE WHICH IS.
UNFORTUNATELY IN A PRESENT. ON
THOSE PRISONS ARE LOCATED DON'T
IN AND JUST CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
EACH ONE OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
HAS AN IMPACT WITHOUT THAT
CENSUS BUREAU ACCOUNT OF THEM
AND THEIR LOCATION. IT MET IT
KIND OF MESSES WITH THE FUNDING
SOURCES OR OR IMPACTS THAT ARE
CREATED BY THEIR EXISTENCE UNDER
THAT RESIDENTIAL AREA OUR
RESIDENTS AREA. NOW THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE GONNA BE
SHORTED- MUCH NEEDED FUNDS. FOR
THE EMERGENCY SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO HIM AND ALL THE HOST
OF OTHER LOCALITY- I SERVICES
ARE BEING PROVIDED. THIS IS
GOING TO DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT THEM HOW DO YOU ADDRESS
THAT I SHORTFALL NOW FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE THAT ARE GOING
TO BE IMPACTED. YEAH RESPECT I
THINK THAT ALL COMMUNITIES
DESERVE TO BE ADEQUATELY
RESOURCE TO THEIR FULL CAPACITY.
I THINK PRISONS- ARTIFICIALLY
INFLATE A LOCAL POPULATION
BECAUSE THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
MOST FOLKS RETURN HOME. AFTER
THEIR TIME IN INCARCERATION. AND
SO THIS IS A PROCESS THAT WAS
RECOMMENDED TO THE CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION THEY
ACCEPTED THAT RECOMMENDATION AND
DECIDED TO DO IT ON THEIR OWN
DURING THE LAST REDISTRICTING
PROCESS. THEY FOUND IT TO BE
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL AND
IMPORTANT- AND TO KIND OF
ADDRESS. AN EQUAL REPRESENTATION
CONCERN WHEN IT COMES TO PRISON
GERRYMANDERING YOU COULD ARGUE
THAT THE HOME DISTRICTS OR
PLACES OR CITIES MUNICIPALITIES
WHERE FOLKS. THIS BOOK TO THE
COP FROM WARM CARS RATED ARE
ALSO SHORT. POTENTIALLY SOME OF
THOSE RESOURCES BECAUSE THEY
DON'T- THAT THEY'RE NOT COUNTED
IN THAT SAME WAY BECAUSE OF OUR
PRISONS ARE LOCATED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND SO. ON TO ME THIS
IS A- A GOOD GOVERNANCE BILL- IN
DRAWING FAIR LINE FOR
REPRESENTATION- AND IT COMES OUT
OF. RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
COMMISSION FROM THE WORK THAT
THEY'VE DONE THIS LAST YEAR-
THERE WERE NO CHALLENGES IT TO
IT THIS LAST PROCESS AND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR SOME
SUPPORT BUT WE CAN KEEP WORKING
ON IT. THROUGH THE PROCESS IN
TERMS OF ADDRESSING ANY ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES- BUT IT IS IT IS A
FORM OF GERRYMANDERING AND I
THINK WE SHOULD ADDRESS. I AND
WE'RE IN AGREEMENT ON ON SEVERAL
OF YOUR POINTS THERE I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE IMPACTED IT'S
NOT JUST THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT
IT'S A NUMBER OF. US THAT HAVE
PRESENCE IN OUR DISTRICT AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
NOT IMPACTED THROUGH THESE
ACTIONS OF YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK ON THAT WE APPRECIATE I
WOULD LOVE TO TALK ABOUT WE CAN
RESOURCES CAN. THANK YOU.
OCTOBER YOUR ARM IT'S NOT CLEAR
TO ME THAT CHANGING THE WAY.
DISTRICTS ARE ALLOCATED NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE. WOULD AFFECT FUNDING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. ON
THE CENSUS NUMBERS ARE STILL THE
CENSUS NUMBERS SO THAT'S
ACTUALLY GREAT POINT. YEAH SO I
WOULD THINK THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES SHOULDN'T. ARE
SUFFER FROM THE CONCERNS THAT-
THE VICE CHAIR HAS I THINK THEY
WOULD CONTINUE TO GET. RESOURCE
THE SAME WAY. I WOULD THINK AND
I APPRECIATE THAT POINTS TO WORK
IN AND I BELIEVE YOU ARE CORRECT
RIGHT LESS ABOUT REPRESENTATION
IN THE POLITICAL PROCESS
CERTAINLY NOT A REVIEW BEING
COUNTED FOR THE SENSES BUT I
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION FEDERAL LEVEL TO.
WELL- I'LL JUST SAY THE TWO OF
YOU CAN WORK IT OUT. I SUSPECT
WE WILL WE WILL. OKAY WE'LL TAKE
THAT AS A CLOSE TO YOUR BILL
BILL IS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
ARE YOU THERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MOVE TO SANTIAGO'S BILLS.
IF WE'RE GOING TO. STAY IN ORDER
APPRECIATE THE- LIMITS TO CARRY
OTHER MEMBERS BILLS IRAQI WILL
COME RIGHT BACK TO- WILL- TAKE
UP. REMEMBER CARRILLO. TWENTY
TWO OH FIVE- THANK. TWENTY TWO
OH FIVE. PAST THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO OH FIVE
THE BILL RELATED TO DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS FOR ABORTION
PREMIUMS THIS BILL IS SPONSORED
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INURANCE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
NATIONAL HEALTH LAWCENTER UNDER
CURRENT LAW HEALTH INSURERS AND
PLANS ARE REQUIRED TO COLLECT
ONE DOLLAR PER ENROLLEE PER
MONTH PREMIUM SPECIFICALLY FOR
ABORTION SERVICES. THERE IS NO
CURRENT REQUIREMENT THAT HEALTH
INSURERS AND PLANS REPORT HOW
MUCH IS COLLECTED AND HOW THE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN USED AB TWENTY
TWO OH FIVE REQUIRES INSURERS TO
SUBMIT AN ANNUAL REPORT
CONTAINING INFORMATION ON HOW
MUCH MONEY IS CURRENTLY IN THE
ACCOUNT AND HOW MUCH IS BEING
USED EACH YEAR TO PAY CLAIMS THE
BILL WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY TO THE FUNDS
AVAILABLE THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED. FOR ABORTION SERVICES
THIS FISCAL THE FISCAL IMPACTS
OF THIS BILL ARE MINOR AND IT'S
HORRIBLE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST LEVEL. THANK R. ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO A COMMON
IN SUPPORT. C. NINE PHONE
OPERATOR WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT ON
TWENTY TWO OH FIVE. WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY TWO OH FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE SOMEONE IN Q. LINE ONE OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
ONE OH SEVEN. HARRY NO ANSWER OF
CLOSE THE LINE THERE'S NO ONE IN
Q. HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION.
TWENTY TWO OH FIVE C. NINE PHONE
OPERATOR WILL ENTERTAIN
OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWO OH FIVE. AN OPPOSITION FOR
TWENTY TWO OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THEN THERE IS
AND- ONE MOMENT PLEASE ONE
PERSON IS IN Q.
UNLINED ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE FIFTEEN. GOOD MORNING
WITH THE CHAIR MEMBERS JUST YOU
CAN VIGOREAUX ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER CONNEMARA
FONG BOB YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THAT THEIR- AND THERE'S NO ONE
LEFT IN Q. ALL ONE MOMENT
THERE'S ONE MORE PERSON QUEUING
UP. WHAT SEEMS.
MY AND ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE FOURTEEN. HI KIM CRAIG
WITH OUR STRATEGIES ON BEHALF.
THAT DIDN'T SUPPORT SORRY FOR
THE LONG WORK AT. BUT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE LEFT IN Q. THANK
YOU ARE. ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM OPPOSITION. SAN NINE PHONE
OPERATOR OPPOSITION. YOUR IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THIS AMERICAN- ONE INK
YOU'LL REVERT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SAY NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OUT ON THE B. ROLL
CALL. THANK YOU. MORE IF YOU
HAVE ONE MORE A TWENTY TWO
TWENTY SIX OH SIX. THE PAST
THANK YOU ALISON. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PROUD TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX OH SIX
TWENTY SIX OH SIX IS A BILL THAT
WOULD PROHIBIT THE DECLINE
PROCEDURE OR A TEN THE NEXT TO
ME ON ANY CAT EXCEPT WHERE THERE
IS A THERAPEUTIC PURPOSE
ELECTIVE DECLINE IS A CRUEL AND
PAINFUL SERIES OF AMPUTATIONS
WITH ABSOLUTELY NO. BENEFIT TO
THE ANIMAL THIS BILL THE
SPONSORED BY THE POP PROJECT AND
THERE ARE NO ANTICIPATED COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BUILT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
. MISTER WHERE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAYER I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE POP PROJECT. WE
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AND ALL THE JOINT AND CO
AUTHORS OF THE MEASURE. THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
CONSIDERATION AND- DRIVE OF.
THANK YOU WILL TURN TO OF THE
HEARING ROOM ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
MOVED TO THE PHONE LINES SUPPORT. FOR TWENTY TWENTY SIX OH SIX.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT FOR TWENTY
SIX OH SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE'VE LINE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SIXTEEN HE MISSED
HER MEMBERS PAUL YODER ON BEHALF
OF CAL ANIMALS IN THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES
BOTH IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
THERE'S ONE MORE PERSON IN KYOTO
BE JUST A MOMENT.
NINE SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN SEVENTY FOUR. HI MY NAME IS
JAMES CHEN SOLD AND I AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE POP PROJECT AND
ALSO- DEMOCRATS FOR THE
PROTECTION OF ANIMALS A
CHARTERED CLUB OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY-
BUT IT ON BEHALF OF BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS- WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
LEFT THANK YOU. HEARING ROOM OFF
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MR JERRY
MEMBERS MIKE DILLON REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WE'RE
STRONGLY OPPOSE BASED ON THE
POLICY AND ALSO THE PRESIDENT
WOULD SAID TO THE VETERINARY
PRACTICE ACT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEE NO OTHERS IN THE
HEARING ROOM WILL TURN TO THE
PHONE LINE PHONE OPERATOR
OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY SIX OH
SIX. YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY SIX OH SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO AT THIS TIME NO
ONE IS IN Q. RATE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF THE THERE'S A
MOTION HAS BEEN SECONDED THE TO
DO PASS. THE BILL IS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING WEBER NOT
VOTING AND VOEPEL VOTING ON.
THANK. RK.
THIS IS A TWENTY SEVENTY THE
PAST AS AMENDED AND YOU ALSO
HAVE A TWENTY EIGHTY THREE WHICH
IS ALSO DID WAS THE TO PASS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AUTHOR
WILL PREVAIL. THANK YOU AMULSAR
AB TWENTY SEVENTY THAT'S
MEDICARE- I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND FOR THE AMENDMENTS AT
WITH. AB TWENTY SEVENTY WILL
INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING PRIOR
NOTIFICATION FROM A UTILITY
COMPANY THE FIRE DISTRICTS WHEN
THE COP THE CONDUCT THAT THEY
ENGAGING IN THESE HIGH RISK FIRE
MITIGATION WORK. IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS
EXPERIENCED AN UNPRECEDENTED
AMOUNT OF WILDFIRES THE TWENTY
TWENTY BEING THE WORST FIRE
SEASON IN MODERN HISTORY.
CALIFORNIA IS NOW ENTERING. A
NEW SEASON WITH ALARMING SPEED
THE LUNAR GONNA GO WILD FIRE IN
ORANGE COUNTY JUST READ AT LEAST
TWENTY HOMES AND HUNDREDS OF
ACRES IN FOLIAGE IN NO TIME.
FIREFIGHTERS ARE OVERSTRETCHED
ALREADY WE ALREADY KNOW THAT.
ANY CLEAR STANDARDIZED
COMMUNICATION ABOUT KNOWN RISKS
TO SUCCESSFULLY MANAGE THE WORK
THEY HAVE AHEAD OF THEM. PRIOR
NOTIFICATION WILL ALLOW FIRE
DISTRICTS TO PREPARE WHEN
UTILITY COMPANIES CONDUCT HOT
WORK WITH CONTROLLED BURNS
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION. FIRE
DISTRICTS DO SO MUCH TO PROTECT
EACH AND EVERYONE OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS IT IS ESSENTIAL
THAT WE GIVE THEM THE TOOLS THEY
NEED ESPECIALLY DURING FIRE
SEASON WHICH IS NOW ALMOST YEAR
ROUND. AB TWENTY SEVENTY SIMPLY
REQUIRES UTILITIES TO SEND AN
EMAIL TO OUR FIRE DISTRICT SO
THEY CAN BE READY. WITH ME TODAY
OVER THE PHONE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OUR FIRE CHIEF PETE.
FIRE CHIEF PETE PAGE MEYER AND
THE SAN RAMON VALLEY FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT FIRE CHIEF
DAVE WINOKUR THE MORAGA ORINDA
FIRE PROTECTION DIST. THANK YOU.
SO WILL HOLD ON TO YOUR
WITNESSES OF THEIR QUESTION
THAT'S RIGHT THINKING OKAY. IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY OR TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT. WILL MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES- WE'RE LOOKING
FOR SUPPORT ON TWENTY SEVENTY.
KERN SUPPORT ON TWENTY SEVENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE OF THEM THEY'RE
ALL. NINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SIXTY SIX. HI THIS IS
BRANDY BACK IF ANY OF IT YOUR
PER OPPOSITION MY APOLOGIES.
THERE'S NO ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME- COME BACK TO THE HEARING
ROOM FOR OPPOSITION ON. TWENTY
SEVENTY. THE LEDGER ADAM SMITH'S
OF THE CALIFORNIA EDISON
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SEVENTY
WERE NOT AWARE OF HOT WORK EVER
HAVING CAUSED A FIRE SO WE THINK
THIS WOULD CREATE DUPLICATIVE
AND UNNECESSARY REPORTING TO
LOCAL FIRE DISTRICTS. THAT'S IT
. GOOD MORNING EAGERLY MELENDEZ
WITHIN YOUR GAS AND ELECTRIC
OFTEN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. A
PHONE LINE OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
SEVENTY. IF YOU ARE AN
ABERRATION A TWENTY SEVENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. LINE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
DIDN'T BRING ANY BACK WITH YOU
NAY WE ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMICS FROM SURPRISE AND FROM
MADISON- WE'RE NOT AWARE OF ANY-
HOT WORK ISSUES AND YOUR BILL IS
UNNECESSARY THANK YOU. AND
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
THEY WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED. OF QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS IT'S OUT
OF WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
MR NASH SECOND BILL IS TWENTY
THREE AND THAT'S ALSO ENJOYS A
DO PASS. THE BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE AND
PRESENTING AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE BILL THAT PROTECTS UTILITY
REPAIRS AND SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS FOR UTILITY BECAUSE
WILDFIRES CURRENTLY WHEN CIVIL
OR CRIMINAL FINES ARE LEVIED
AGAINST ELECTRICAL OR GAS
UTILITY COMPANY IN A COURT OF
LAW RELATING TO WILDFIRE
CONVICTIONS CALIFORNIA LAW FOR
BIDS THE COMPANIES. FROM USING
RATEPAYER FUNDS TO COVER THIS
PENALTY HOWEVER THERE'S A
LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW THAT
ALLOWS THOSE SAME UTILITIES USE
RATEPAYER FUNDS TO COVER THESE
FINES AND PENALTIES A SETTLEMENT
IS REACHED PRIOR TO TRIAL WITH
THE COUNTY CITY OR STATE. AB
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE WILL CLOSE
THAT LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT NOT
INSURED THE REPAIR FUNDS ARE
PROTECTED THE SAME WAY THEY
WOULD BE IF THE TRIAL AND SUED
AS YOU NOW STATE THIS YEAR THE
BILL HAS ZERO FISCAL IMPACT ON
THE STATE AND WITH ME TODAY BY
PHONE. I'M TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IS KATIE MORE SONY
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK. FULLER TWO OF
THE PHONE OPERATOR IN KATY MORE
SUNNY. YES GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS KATIE MARCONI AND I AM A
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK ALSO KNOWN AS
TURN TURN THE PROUD SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL PROTECTING RATEPAYERS
FROM FUNDING ANY SETTLEMENT
RELATED EXPENSES THAT THE
UTILITY AGREED TO IN ORDER TO
AVOID PROSECUTION. HE JEANNIE
RECENTLY REACHED A SETTLEMENT
WITH SEVERAL NORTHERN COUNTIES
TO AVOID CRIMINAL CHARGES
RELATED TO A UTILITIES BECAUSE
BUYERS. THE SETTLEMENT REMEDIES
INCLUDE NEW POSITIONS AND
WEATHER STATION SOMEONE HOWEVER
NEED A PRETTY IS AND IT SHOULD
BE SHAREHOLDERS. THE BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT THE UTILITIES- THINKING
ANY COSTS RELATED T A
SETTLEMENT AND ANY RAPE CASE
WITHOUT THIS BILL IT WOULD BE
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF RATEPAYER
ADVOCATE TO TRACKING ENSURE ANY
COSTS RELATED TO THAT. OR OTHER
SETTLEMENTS ARE NOT RECOVERED
FROM GREAT CARES. HELLO IN THE
STATE BECAUSE TO BE PASSED
THROUGH TO RATEPAYERS. THE
PURPOSES OF HOLDING UTILITY
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE FAILED
OPERATIONS OF THE FACILITY. THIS
BILL WILL NOT IMPACT STATE FUND
THE BILL WILL ALSO STREAMLINE
YOUR REVIEW OF UTILITY COST
RECOVERY APPLICATIONS BY MAKING
CLEAR THAT COMPETITION. ON
RECOVERING THESE COSTS. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU I WILL
TURN TO THE HEARING- IS THERE
ANYONE HERE AND SUPPORT. OF
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE SEEN NONE
OWNER OPERATOR WILL TAKE OP WILL
TAKE OPPOSITION NO SUPPORT I'M
SORRY SUPPORT ON TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT ON
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. LINE ONE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
TWENTY THREE. LINE ONE TWENTY
THREE. AND THEY HAVE REMOVED
THEMSELVES THERE IS NO ONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. BACK TO THE
HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY THREE. UNICAL INNOCENT
SENDING A GAS AND ELECTRIC ALSO
OPPOSITION AS SOMETIMES THE
CIVIL SETTLEMENTS THAT INCLUDE-
HARDENING AND SO THAT'S MORE
PROPERLY AT THE PC- DECISIONS OF
THANK YOU NO POSITION. ADAM
SMITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
ALSO OPPOSED. WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES OPPOSITION AT. TWO
TWENTY THREE. YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
. THEY HAVE LINE SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN SIXTY SIX. HI
BRANDY ABOUT WHAT PACIFIC THE
LETTER BUT WE ARE FOCUSED ON THE
REASONS OUTLINED IN OUR A
LETTER- BUT MUCH. AND NO ONE
ELSE'S THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY THANK YOU- THEY WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
AND WE HAVE THE BILL IS OUT.
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
VOEPEL IS AND I AM CALDERON NOT
VOTING THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST. WHICH CALL AUDIBLE ON THE
ON THE LINE HERE. ALL RIGHT.
CALDERONE YOU READY PERCENT WILL.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA USE THREE
ALTERNATE ALTERNATIVE PROJECT
DELIVERY METHODS TO EXPEDITE THE
CONSTRUCTION DROUGHT RESPONSE
WATER PROJECTS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IS CATHY VIA TELEPHONE
BEHALF OF THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
. ARE YOUR MICROPHONE. EVERY AS
A BETTER DECISION OKAY THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KATHY
VIA TELL AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE THE SPONSORS OF AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE. METROPOLITAN IS A
REGIONAL WHOLESALER THAT
DELIVERS WATER TO TWENTY SIX
MEMBER AGENCIES SERVING NINETEEN
MILLION PEOPLE. LIVING IN LOS
ANGELES ORANGE RIVERSIDE SAN
BERNARDINO. SAN DIEGO AND
VENTURA COUNTIES AND LOCAL
BUSINESSES. CALIFORNIA AS YOU
KNOW IS IN HERE THREE OF A
WORSENING DROUGHT. AND JANUARY
FEBRUARY AND MARCH WERE THE
THREE DRIEST CONSECUTIVE MONTHS
ON RECORD. DRINKING ALLOCATIONS
FROM THE STATE WATER PROJECT AND
THE FIRST EVER WATER SHORTAGE
DECLARED. ON THE COLORADO RIVER
LAY BARE. A LONG TERM RISKS OF
DROUGHT ON SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
WATER SUPPLY. AND IN RESPONSE
METROPOLITAN IS WORKING TO
EXPEDITE. A NEW REGIONAL
RECYCLED WATER PROGRAM THAT
COULD PROVIDE. FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOMES WITH THE DROUGHT
PROOF SUPPLY OF WATER. AND A SET
OF EMERGENCY MITIGATION PROJECTS
TO MAKE OUR REGIONAL
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM MORE CLIMATE
RESILIENT. AND FLEXIBLE SO WE
CAN MOVE WATER THAT WE HAVE
STORED LOCALLY. AS A PUBLIC
AGENCY WE ARE CURRENTLY LIMITED
TO TRADITIONAL DESIGN BID BUILD
MODEL FOR DELIVERY OF PUBLIC
WORKS. CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS
WHICH CAN BE INEFFICIENT AND
INFLEXIBLE. FOR LARGE COMPLEX
AND TIME SENSITIVE PROJECTS LIKE
WHAT WE HAVE PLANNED.
METROPOLITAN IS SEEKING
AUTHORIZATION TO USE THREE
ADDITIONAL PROJECT DELIVERY
METHODS. THAT WILL ENHANCE OUR
ABILITY TO DELIVER KEY WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN AN
EFFICIENT AND TIMELY MANNER.
THIS WILL HELP US IN OUR REGION
AND THE MANY WATER AGENCIES AND
BUSINESSES THAT DEPEND ON
METROPOLITAN. THE DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY RELIABLE SUPPLIES AS WE
PREPARE FOR FUTURE CLIMATE
CHANGE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. WE'LL TURN TO THE
HEARING ROOM. OF PUBLIC COMMENT
TO A IN SUPPORT. C. NINE WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES PHONE
OPERATOR WILL TAKE COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE
MOVE THE BILL. YOUR SUPPORT
418-404-0518 FORTY FIVE.
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE THANK YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AT
THIS TIME THERE IS NO HOPE ONE
MOMENT THERE'S ONE PERSON IN Q.
NINE ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE THIRTY. THANK YOU AND
SORRY ABOUT THE DELAY ALLEN CHAN
ASKS ME LOCAL NINETEEN OH TWO
EXECUTIVE PRESIDENT REPRESENTING
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
INCLUDES IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. AND
THERE'S N ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE HEARING ROOM
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE. THE NON PHONE OPERATOR.
OPPOSITION EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE.
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE MAN THEY'RE ALL. AND THERE
IS NOT WANTING TO AT THIS TIME
IT WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEES. NO COMMENTS OF THIS
IS THAT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE BILL IS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. APPEL VOTING NO
VINCE FONG AND I. THANK YOU MR
OKAY. HEY LET'S SEE- WE'RE GONNA
MOVE BACK TO ITEM THREE. OF FOR
A TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE BLOOM
DR QUIRK WILL BE PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF. SOMEONE EVER BLOOM.
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE
ENJOYS A DO PASS. THE MOVE IS
THEIR SECOND. WILSON SAID. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY NINE WOULD ENSURE
LOCATIONS WHEREEMERGENCY
SHELTERS AND OTHER INTRUM HAS
SEEN CAN BE BUILT ARE SUITABLE
AVAILABLE AND SUFFICIENT TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS. BILL
WOULD ALSO CLARIFY THAT NOTED
THAT THAT THAT THAT THE NO NET
LOSS LAW APPLIES TO BOTH CARRY
OVER SITES AND SITES IDENTIFIED.
KEEP THE CURRENT REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT RINA
PROCESS. OF TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OR WELL PERHAPS
ANSWERING QUESTIONS IS- BRIAN A
GUSTO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. AND THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT THE
BILL HAS MINOR ABSORB COST. THE
STATE AND A LOCAL OUR COSTS ARE
NOT REIMBURSABLE. THANK YOU-
BRANIGAN'S TO YOUR OKAY WITH
JUST ANSWERING QUESTIONS IF
THERE ARE ANY. YEAH YES CHAIR
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA VOTE THANK
YOU I WILL LOOK TO THE HEARING
ROOM IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO.
THE COMMON IN SUPPORT GOING TO
THE PHONE LINES PHONE OPERATOR
WILL TAKE SUPPORT. FOR TWENTY
THREE THIRTY NINE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT FOR TWENTY THREE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME THERE IS NO
ONE IN Q. HEARING ROOM
OPPOSITION. IN OPPOSITION PHONE
OPERATOR OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
THREE THIRTY NINE. IF YOU ARE OP
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY THREE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME NO ONE
IS IN QUEUE. THEY WERE VERY BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS
OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO. A MOVE TO
CONSENT FOR A MOMENT IF WE COULD
AND WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION. FOR
THE CONCERT. NO SECRETARY ROQUE
READ THE CONSENT I'D. THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE ALL AB'S
ASSEMBLY BILLS AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE NINETEEN OH TWO
AGUIAR-CURRY TWENTY TWELVE I
GALA CURRY TWENTY THIRTY NINE
GALLAGHER TWENTY EIGHTY ONE
BERMAN TWENTY THREE TWENTY SIX
REYES TWENTY THREE THIRTY
BIGELOW TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO
CERVANTES TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE
ANGULAR CURRY TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE MCCARTY TWENTY SIX OH FOUR
CALDERON TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE
BLANCA RUBIO TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
SIX ON THIAGO. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE MULLIN 28-7 T.
SANTIAGO TWENTY NINE TWENTY ONE
SANTIAGO TWENTY NINE SIXTY TWO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY TWENTY
NINE SIXTY SEVEN COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
ONE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
TWO COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I BIGELOW
BIGELOW I. BRIAN BRIAN I
CALDERON CALDERON I CARILLO I
MEGAN DOLLY REAGANITE AYE VOEPEL
VOEPEL I MIGHT FONG MY PHONE I
VINCE FONG. GABRIEL EDUARDO
GARCIA LEVINE LOOK. FOUR HI I
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS II
WEBER ÔER I
THANK ELLENDER IS APPROVED. I
WILL LOOK TO TAKE UP THE
SUSPENSE FILE IF WE COULD.
SECRETARY FOR THROUGH THE
CONSECUTIVE TO SPECIFY. THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ALL ASSEMBLY
BELLS AB SIXTEEN TWENTY AGILA
CURRY. SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE RAMA
SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR ROBERT RIVAS
SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO GIPSON
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE OH IN
SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE VOEPEL
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN HOLDEN
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT CRISTINA
GARCIA EIGHTEEN SEVENTIES STONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY THREE
QUIRK-SILVA EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE
CHOI EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE
EDUARDO GARCIA EIGHTEEN NINETY
SIX COKE AT NINETEEN ELEVEN
GABRIEL NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
PETRIE-NORRIS NINETEEN THIRTY.
ARAMBULA NINETEEN THIRTY ONE
THREE OF US NINETEEN FORTY SALAS
NINETEEN FORTY ONE SALAS.
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE GRAYSON NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WILSON NINETEEN FIFTY NINE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE IN THIS
AREA. FRANCO OF. NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WARD NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO SANTIAGO NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT SMITH. TWENTY OH TO
BE VALLAPUDUA TWENTY ELEVEN
WICKS TWENTY NINETEEN
PETRIE-NORRIS TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
FRIEDMAN TWENTY TWENTY NINE
WICKS TWENTY THIRTY TWO EDUARDO
GARCIA TWENTY THIRTY FOUR OR
DONALD TWENTY FORTY TWO V.
VALLAPUDUA TWENTY FIFTY FIVE
LOVE TWENTY EIGHTY WOULD TWENTY
EIGHTY NINE BALLOT QUE HAN
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. COULD BE A
TWENTY ONE SIXTY MCCARTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY FIVE FONG TWENTY ONE
THIRTY ONE MULLIN. TWENTY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR. WEBER TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO
APRIL TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE
ARAMBULA TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE
RUBIO TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX
GRAYSON TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE
WICKS. TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
ARAMBULA TWENTY TWO OH ONE
BENNETTS 221-110-2213 I GALA
CURRY TWENTY TWO TWENTY SIX
CERVANTES TWENTY TO THIRTY TWO
MCCARTY TWENTY TWO THIRTY THREE
QUIRK-SILVA TWENTY TWO FORTY TWO
SANTIAGO. TWENTY TO SEVENTY FIVE
WOULD TWENTY TO SEVENTY SIX
KHEDIRA TWENTY TWO EIGHTY ONE
LACKEY TWENTY TWO NINETY EIGHT
MAYES TWENTY THREE HUNDRED KALRA
TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN WAR TWENTY
THREE SEVENTEEN RAMOS TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE THREE OF US
TWENTY THREE SIXTY ARAMBULA
TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE ME UPON
TO TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX
BETWEEN THE HOURS. TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT- IN TWENTY FOUR OH
TWO BLANCA RUBIO TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ARAMBULA TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT FRIEDMAN. TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY NINE BLOOM TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY FOUR JONES SAWYER
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SIX MCCARTY
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE
CERVANTES. TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
THREE MISSOURIAN TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY FIVE QUIRK-SILVA TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY ARAMBULA TWENTY FOUR
NINETY ONE CERVANTES TWENTY FOUR
NINETY NINE MAIENSCHEIN TWENTY
FIVE FOURTEEN MEGAN DOLLY TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTEEN MIA BONTA. TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY TWO GREAT TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY NINE DAVIES TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY THREE OCT TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY COME THEM TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY ONE SALAS TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN EDUARDO
GARCIA. TWENTY FIVE NINETY
ARAMBULA. 259-014-2590 SEVEN
BLOOM. TWENTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT
WEBER TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN
RODRIGUEZ TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWO
MULLIN TWENTY SIX TWENTY FOUR
KALRA. TWENTY SIX THIRTY- DONNA
TWENTY SIX THE TA BLOOM TWENTY
SIX FIFTY ONE PETRIE-NORRIS
TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO MCCARTY
TWENTY SIX FIFTY THREE SANTIAGO
TWENTY SIX TO SIXTY THREE RAMOS
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX DOLLARS
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
THREE- IN TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR. COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SIX COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS TWENTY SIX NINE FIVE
BERMAN TWENTY SEVEN OH TO GIPSON
TWENTY SEVEN OF FIVE
QUIRK-SILVA. TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR ARAMBULA TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY WANTING TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT REYES TWENTY EVEN
FORTY SIX FRIEDMAN TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT HOLDEN TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY ONE EDUARDO GARCIA TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY THREE REYES TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE MURATSUCHI.
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE SANTIAGO
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT WALDRON. TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY BROUGH
VALLAPUDUA TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR WEBER TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
SIX STONE TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
FOUR GIPSON TWENTY EIGHT OH SIX
RUBIO. TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTEEN
REYES TWENTY EIGHTEEN WALDRON
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO
ROBERT RIVAS TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
ONE EDUARDO GARCIA TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY FOUR ROBERT RIVAS TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE JONES SAWYER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN MIA BONTA TWENTY
EIGHTY ONE BERMAN TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE WEEKS
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY THREE DOLLY.
DALY TWENTY EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
FONG TWENTY NINE ELEVEN
RESEARCHER TWENTY NINE TWENTY
ARAMBULA. TWENTY NINE TWENTY
NINE EDUARDO GARCIA TWENTY NINE
THIRTY THREE- DONNA TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SEVEN CALDERON TWENTY
NINE FORTY NINE LEAD TWENTY NINE
FIFTY GRAY. TWENTY NINE SIXTY
FOUR COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR
COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY.
THANK YOU THE SUSPENSE CALENDARS
IN APPROVED WILL NOW MOVEBACK
TO OUR BILL PRESENTATIONS. AS
WILSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
FOR QUIRK-SILVA.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE INTO THE
JOYS A DO PASS. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY ONE ON BEHALF OF OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYWOMAN SHARON
QUIRK-SILVA AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
ONE WILL CLARIFY EXISTING LAW TO
HELP EXPEDITE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A SENSORY DWELLING UNITS ALSO
KNOWN AS EIGHTY YEARS. LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA BROKE THE EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR MEDIAN
HOME PRICE MARK FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN HISTORY WE WANT TO
SUPPORT WORKING CALIFORNIANS IN
THEIR PURSUIT OF THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM OF HOME OWNERSHIP AND WE
MUST MAKE HOMES MORE AFFORDABLE.
EIGHTY USE ARE PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS AND THIS MEASURE WILL
SPEED UP THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING ACROSS CALIFORNIA WITH
ME IN PERSON TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS LEAST MERON TAKE
WITH CALIFORNIA YIMBY. AND
JOINING US OVER THE TELEPHONE AS
ANY FRYMAN THE DIRECTOR OF
CITIES AT ABBOTT MISSY BUT- I
THINK THE FACE OF THAT ALRIGHT I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. IT WITH CALIFORNIA BE
ON THURSDAY THE TWENTY. THE BILL
WILL MAKE. A LOT OF THREE THIRTY. NOPE THAT'S IT. CORRECTED WITH
STATE. MANDATES TO BUILD THREE
MAFIA. LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR ANY
PART FOR JUST SECOND DOESN'T
SELL LIKE COMING THROUGH AMERICA
OKAY- SORRY ABOUT THAT OKAY. THE
WAY THE GORGEOUS WRAP UP IF
THAT'S OKAY THE S. THAT THE BILL
WOULD NOT HAVE ANY COST TO THE
STATE BECAUSE ANY MANDATE THE
BILL WOULD CREATE WOULD NOT BE
REIMBURSABLE AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN RECOVER FOR. A
COST CREATED BY STATE HOUSING
LEGISLATION FROM FEES THAT THEY
CAN IMPOSE ON HOUSING CURRENTLY
. THANK YOU WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR YOUR OTHER
WITNESS. ANY FRYMAN. SANDY
FRYMAN ONLINE ON THE PHONE LINE. THEY WILL MOVE ON IT WILL
ENTERTAINER COMMENTS AS HE JOINS
US LATER WILL LOOK TO THE
HEARING ROOM FOR SUPPORT. PHONE
OPERATOR WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES SUPPORT ON. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY ONE. HERE IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY TO TWENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THE LINE
ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE THIRTY FIVE. ONE ONE
THIRTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
SHAREHOLDERS AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS VANESSA DANIELLE MURRELL FROM
PARENTS PUBLIC SCHOOLS
ENCAMPMENTS DISCO I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN NOPE THAT'S NOT THE
ONE THE PUBLIC I'M SORRY WE'RE
NOT OFF WE'RE ON. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE. THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. OKAY
WELCOME BACK TO THE HEARING ROOM
OPPOSITION. THEY NINE PHONE
OPERATOR OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY
TO TWENTY ONE. AND OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY TO TWENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WHEN
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. THEY WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
NO QUESTIONS THIS IS ON A ROLL
CALL. THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
REAVIS WOULD YOU. LIKE TO
PRESENT FOR MISTER NAZARIAN AND
THEN I BELIEVE YOU HAVE. YOUR
BILLS PERCENT AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND SO IF
YOU LIKE I CAN DO ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE SEVEN SIX FIVE YES THE
GIANTS ON BEHALF OF OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARIAN
AS LEGISLATION SENATE BILL ONE
SEVEN SIX FIVE IS CLEAN UP
LEGISLATION A FOR- ASSEMBLY BILL
AT SEVEN FIVE EIGHT WHICH WAS.
PASSED AND SIGNED JUST LAST YEAR
- THIS CURRENT LEGISLATION SEEKS
TO AUTHORIZE THE CALIFORNIA
POLLUTION CONTROL FINANCING
AUTHORITY WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
TREASURE'S OFFICE TO CHARGE
ADDITIONAL FEES TO RETAIN AN
INDEPENDENT- A FINANCIAL ADVISER
TO REVIEW. APPLICATIONS FOR RATE
REDUCTION BONDS OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS R. ARBY'S. POINTED WITH
ANNOUNCES THEIR NOTE STATE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL. I
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
CASEY O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TREASURER THANK YOU MR
JOHN. BELL PERFECT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS I'LL
KEEP IT BRIEF WITH THE MOVEMENT
THIS IS JUST CODIFYING SOMETHING
WE ALREADY HAVE IN REGULATIONS.
IT COSTS NO MONEY TO THE STATE
OR TO C. P. CFA I JUST HAVE
SHEILA DEVICE DANIEL HERE WITH
ME IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR CBC AVE WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
HEARING ROOM SUPPORT. THE NON
SUPPORT ONLINE. FOR SEVENTEEN
SIXTY FIVE. IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
FOR SEVENTEEN SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. HEY
THE HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE PHONE LINE
OPPOSITION. SEVENTEEN SIXTY
FIVE. IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
SEVENTEEN SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. THEY
WERE VERY BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SINGLE COMMENTS THIS BILL IS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL WITH DOLLY.
INVENTS FONG NOT VOTING. MISTER
REVERSE YOU HAVE- THE FOR SEPT
TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR. YES
MISTER CHEST SO- THIS IS A TWO
TO THREE FOR A SIX TO CREATE
pTO PROPOSED ENTITLEMENT
RESIDENTIAL BUILDING PERMITS.
NOW TO BE CLEAR THIS LEGISLATION
ONLY AFFECTS PERMITS. THAT ARE
ISSUED AFTER AFTER A PROJECT HAS
BEEN APPROVED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCY AND AFTER ANY
C. QUOTE REVIEW AS OUR STATE
CONTINUES EXPERIENCE A WORSENING
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. IS
THAT THIS LEGISLATION WILL GO A
LONG WAY TO IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY
AND PREDICTABILITY GREAT
EFFICIENCIES FOR BOTH HOME
BUILDERS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
NEGLIGIBLE A WITH ME- HERE THIS
MORNING TO HELP ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS COREY
SMITH WITH THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION. BUT THAT'S WHAT I'VE
OPPOSITION MOVE THE BELL.
THERE'S MOTIONS- SECOND. AND
SECOND AB MOVED AND SECONDED
WILL LOOK TO ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM OTHER WOULD LIKE TO
LEND THEIR SUPPORT. TWENTY TWO
YEAH- NEED. WE'D WITNESS COREY
SMITH. ABOUT THE ACTION
COALITION YES IF YOU'RE OKAY
WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO YOU IF WE
HAVE QUESTIONS. YES SIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY THANK YOU.
OWNER OPERATOR SUPPORT FOR
TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR. HERE YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY TO
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NO WAY OF LINE EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AS MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
BOB NEAL REPRESENTING FIELD
STEAD COMPANY OWNED BY HOWARD
AHMANSON JUNIOR ORANGE COUNTY
PHILANTHROPISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF MR REDUCES BILL.
AND NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME HEARING ROOM
OPPOSITION. C. NINE WILL TURN TO
THE PHONE LINES OPPOSITION ON.
TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR. YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY TO THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ALL. AT THIS TIME NO ONE
IS IN Q. WILL LOOK TO THE
COMMITTEE SCENE NO COMMENTS ON
THIS WE'RE HAVE THIS BILL. AS A
DO PASS AND IT'S OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO FOR
THE BILL Q. FOUR FOUR TWO IS-THAT LEGISLATION AVAIL NEXT TO
CLEARLY DEFINE CLIMATE CHANGE IS
A HAZARD UNDERSTATE LAW ADDING
CLIMATE CHANGE THE DEFINITION OF
DISASTER THAT CALIFORNIA'S ASTOR
SYSTEMS ACT ONE ABLE BETTER
INTEGRATION OF CLIMATE
MITIGATION AND ADAPTATION
PLANNING AT BOTH THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS- CLARIFYING THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A HAZARD COULD
ALSO OPEN UP. NEW US IN DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS FUNDING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CALAVERAS IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ASSISTED
EXPECTED TO BE NEGLIGIBLE WITH
ME HERE TO HELP- ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS. LUCAS
THE WRECKS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY BUT THAT'S
RIGHT THEY CAN THANK YOU THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION IS OUR SECOND THIS
THE TO PASS. THE NEW LONDON
SECOND IT WILL LOOK TO THE
HEARING ROOM. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT LOOK AT FACTS ON
BEHALF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
STATE COSTS. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
YOUR IN ROOM AND A SUPPORT.
OWNER OPERATOR WILL TAKE SUPPORT
ON TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO. HERE
IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY FOUR FORTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. YOUR IN
ROOM OPPOSITION THEY NINE
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO. IN
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY FOUR FORTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND THERE'S NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY WILL LOOK TO THE
HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION. THE NUN
PHONE LINE OPPOSITION. YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
THEY WILLBRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THIS BILL IS OUT ON
THE B. ROLL CALL. THIS WORKS.
MOVE THE BELL. A THIS IS TWENTY
THREE THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU FOR
THE MOTION THE SECOND THANK YOU
ARE. SIR SHARED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE STAFF
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND FOR AND
FOR THERE'S ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS BY
INCREASING THAT UNIVERSE OF
SITES AVAILABLE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED IN OUR SATE.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S A GAP OF
ONE POINT TWO MILLION HOMES
AFFORDABLE TO STRUGGLING LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITH ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY LIVING
ON OUR STREETS. AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR BUILT ON RECENT
IMPROVEMENTS TO AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY THREE. I OUR DEAR FRIEND
MR CHU. BY ALLOWING A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
TO RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL CENTER
FROM THE LOCAL AGENCY. ADDED
HEIGHT AND UNLIMITED DENSITY OF
THE PROJECT IS LOCATED IN
URBANIZED. VERY LOW V. M. T.
AREA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABOUT THANK YOU DO YOU EVER
WITNESS. BRING A WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR THE
BELL AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR. I LOSE MONDAY WITH
CALIFORNIA BE HERE IN SUPPORT
THANKS THANK YOU. WILL MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES SUPPORT TWENTY
THREE THIRTY FOUR WICKS. AND
SOME PART OF TWENTY THREE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. Q. HEARING
ROOM OPPOSITION. SINAN PHONE
OPERATOR WILL TAKE OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR. YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
THREE THIRTY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL. WE DO HAVE
ONE A LINE THANK YOU IT'S ONE OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREGORY CLAIM ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. NUMBER ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU WE'LL TURN IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE- THIS BILL IS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU.
THIS MCCARTY.
TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO ENJOYS A
DO PASS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS A BILL HELPS ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING SUPPLY ISSUE BUT ALSO
HELPS OUR DOWNTOWN WE KNOW THAT
THE PEOPLE RETURN TO WORK NOT
ALL OF THEIR WORKERS ARE GOING
TO GO BACK IN SERVICE WITH HELP
UTILIZED. STATE ASSETS IN URBAN
CORE AREAS TO TRANSITION. THANK
YOU THANK YOU TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TO SUPPORT. HEARING HER SAY NONE
. TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO SUPPORT
ON PHONE LINE. CURRENT SUPPORT
OF TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO PLEASE
PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO. AND THERE
IS NO WARNING QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THEY WERE TURNED BACK TO THE
HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION. THE NON
OWNER OPERATOR OPPOSITION. TO
TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO. YOUR IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ALL. THERE IS NO ONE IN
Q. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE BILLS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. SENATOR SIERRA. A. B.
TWENTY FIVE OH THREE. RESIDUE
PASS. THANK YOU. I AB TWENTY
FIVE WITH THREE INSTRUCTS THE
LAW REVISION COMMISSION TO STUDY
AND ESTABLISHED UNIFORM
TERMINOLOGY DESCRIBING THE
VARIOUS TERMS FOR LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS AND REPORT THAT BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE THE BILL HAS
MINIMAL COSTS THAT SHOULD BE
ABSORBED THE CURRENT BUDGET OF
THE MISSION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT.
PHONELINE PHONE OPERATOR SUPPORT
FOR TWENTY FIVE OH THREE. HERE
IN SUPPORT FOR TWENTY FIVE OH
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEY'RE ALL. AND THERE'S NO ONE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM
SAYING NINE PHONE OPERATOR
OPPOSITION ONLINE ONLINE FOR
TWENTY FIVE OH THREE. IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION FOR TWENTY FIVE OR
THREE. S. ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL.
THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. THEY WERE
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THIS
BILL IS OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL
. MR GABRIEL.
NINETEEN NINETY ONE THIS HAS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION MOVE THE
BILL. IT INSECT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
AS WE ALL KNOW WHAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE- FAR TOO MANY PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING SHELTER PROGRAMS
OR RESIDING TEMPORARILY IN
HOTELS MOTELS OR OTHER SITES AND
UNFORTUNATELY. MANY FOLKS WAS
FORCED TO SHUFFLE BETWEEN MOTEL
ROOMS OR HOTEL ROOMS EVERY FOUR
WEEKS TO AVOID CREATING A
LANDLORD TENANT RELATIONSHIP IN
THIS SHUFFLING PROCESS IS
PARTICULARLY DESTRUCTIVE FOR
FAMILIES I IT UNNECESSARILY
CONSUMES THE RESOURCE AS A
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS AND IT'S
ALSO. IT DIS INCENTIVIZED AS A
LOT OF FOLKS FROM PUTTING THEIR
PROPERTIES ON THE MARKET TO DO
THIS SO THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
PROTECTIONS FOR VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. PROVIDE SOME
CLARITY AROUND LANDLORD TENANT
RELATIONSHIPS SO THAT FOLKS CAN.
STAY IN ONE PLACE RATHER MOVING
AROUND- AND WE'VE WORKED WITH
GROUPS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BUILDING IN. STRONG PENITENTIAL
PROTECTIONS AND NOT ON ON IN
INADVERTENTLY WEAKENING THEM I'M
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY OR TWO
WITNESSES. ZACH WARM THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF POLICY AT
LA FAMILY HOUSING AND DONNA TANG
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS ANALYST AT-
LOSS OF THE LOS ANGELES HOMELESS
SERVICES AUTHORITY. IN THIS BILL
HAS NOTE A LOSS TO THE STATE
THANK YOU FOR GOOD RETURN YOUR
WITNESSES ACCURATE WARMER. AND
DONNA TANG. ON THE PHONE. GOOD
MORNING CARE ALL THAT. GOOD
MORNING GERALD IN AN HONORABLE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ZACHARY
WARMASTER THE DIRECTOR POLICY
DALY FAMILY HOUSING ONE OF THE
LARGEST HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND FORMAL WHAT ABOUT
THE BALLOT RECENTLY COUNTY.
ELEVATED THE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
AB NINETEEN NINETY ONE BECAUSE
FOR TOO LONG WE'VE SEEN HOW GAPS
IN STATE LAW FORCED FAMILIES
FROM STABLE SHORT TERM OUT. OF
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN. THE BILL
INTRODUCED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
INJURES FAMILIES AND OF.
PARTICIPATING IN SHORT TERM
HELPING LOCATE MOTEL OR HOTEL
CANNOT BE SHOVEL IT THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THE PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE PROTECTED FROM
UNNECESSARY RESTRICTION AND
SHE'S. FURTHERMORE THE BILL
ESTABLISHES CLEAR PROCEDURES AND
GUIDELINES AROUND EXITING
INDIVIDUALS FROM PROGRAMS. THE
ABSENCE OF SUCH UNIFORM
PROPHECIES LAPPER INCONSISTENT
SERVICE RUSH ACROSS BOTH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. STATE AB NINETEEN
NINETY ONE IS COMMON SENSE
LEGISLATION THAT PROVIDE
DESPERATELY NEEDED CLARITY STATE
LAW IN A WAY THAT BENEFITS
PARTICIPANTS PROVIDERS AND
OPERATORS ALIKE I RESPECTFULLY
AFTER NIGHT BUT ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
ATTAINING. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS DONNA
PAYING AND I'M- ACTUALLY THAT
AFFAIRS ANALYST AT MARTHA. ALSO
KNOWN AS THE LOCHEND OF COMMERCE
STARTED WITH THE PARTY AND I
SAID TO SPEAK WITH. THE PLAYER
AT EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE. WE ARE
THE MAIN ADMINISTRATORS OF
OURSELVES PROGRAMS IN LOS
ANGELES. ASSEMBLY LACK
PERSPECTIVE I WANT TO KNOW WHY
AB. NINETEEN NINETY ONE IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US. THE NEW
TOWARD USING THE NON. BY THE-
DEVELOPMENT HOTEL ROOMS AND
OTHER NON CALL OPTIONS GIVE
PEOPLE OF PRIDE. AGENCY SOME OF
THEM ARE IN THEIR- BY INTO HOW.
BUT WITH THIS AND OF
COMPLICATIONS ARISE. AND AB
NINETEEN NINETY WANTED PEOPLE TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM. BECAUSE OF
THE AMBIGUITY IN ST MARTIN ROUND
KEVIN DE INSURANCE PROGRAMS. WE
SEE MORE TALK THAN HOTELS WITH
SPECIALLY IN THE SCATTERED
LIGHT. MOTEL VOUCHER PROGRAM
SHUTTLING PEOPLE BETWEEN ROOMS
ARE RESORTING TO OTHER PRACTICES
OUT OF CONCERN OF CLIENTS IN THE
PROGRAMS. WILL BE RIGHT
ATTENDANCES. J. MANAGERS NOW
YOU'LL CRIME AND WE NEEDED THE
IN OF THE MONTH THE STOCK WILL.
WHEN REALLY WE WANT KEEP MAN BUT
ON COMMON HOUSING FOR THE- AB
NINETEEN NINETY ONE WITH CLEAR
THE TENDENCY. OF THIS NOW REYES
IN TERM HOW YOU CAN. ENSURE
HOTEL THE MOST DON'T PEOPLE
BETWEEN DON'T MOVE PEOPLE
BETWEEN. ALSO AGREED A PRINTER
DAY THE TEACHERS THEN RIGHT BUT
PEOPLE. AIMS PROGRAM. RIGHT AT
ASSEMBLY DO REAL NOW WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING TO GET PEOPLE
CONTENT RIGHT GROUPS INSURANCE
THAT WE'RE NOT IN THE CREATING
FOR. I NEED. HAVE ONLY MADE THE
BILL STRONGER THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY AND ESPECIALLY
AFTER ABOUT. THANK YOU I WILL
LOOK TO THE HEARING ROOM FOR
SUPPORT. SAY NONE PHONE OPERATOR
WILL TAKE SUPPORT A NINETEEN
NINETY ONE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF NINETEEN NINETY ONE
PLEASE TRUST ONE THEN ZERO. ONE
ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH GOOD MORNING- SHARE
MEMBERS THIS IS THE EXTENT OF
ALL HAPPY PEOPLE ASSISTING THE
HOMELESS WE ARE A- SHELTER
PROGRAM PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE UNTIL A
HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION. THEY
NINE PHONE OPERATOR OPPOSITION
ON NINETEEN NINETY ONE. WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF NINETEEN NINETY
ONE PLEASE PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO.
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE- COMMITTEE. ZERO
COMMENTS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU. RIGHT YOU HAVE TO
SANTIAGO BILLS TO.
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU CHU
REMEMBERS AB SIXTY NINE IF I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE PRODUCTION
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN
THE MOST EFFICIENT ABOUT COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL REQUIRE THAT ANY
NOTICE OF FUNDING AVAILABLE
ISSUED BY H. C. D. FOR
AFFORDABLE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
LOAN OR GRANT PROGRAM. ALSO SAY
THAT ADAPTIVE RE USE AS AN
ELIGIBLE ACTIVITY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. COSTS A CD ARE MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO RESPECTFULLY AS FIAT.
THANK YOU WILL LOOK TO THE
HEARING ROOM FOR SUPPORT. PHONE
OPERATOR SUPPORT ON SIXTEEN
NINETY FIVE. HERE IN SUPPORT OF
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE NINE ZERO. AND THERE IS NO
ONE IN Q. OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THERE ARE NONE
OPPOSITION ONLINE PHONE OPERATOR
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE OPPOSITION.
YOUR IN OPPOSITION SIXTEEN
NINETY FIVE PLEASE TRUST ONE
ZERO. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. A
VERY BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THIS
BILL IS OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL
WITH VINCE FONG NOT VOTING.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE TO PASS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY FIVE THE
BELL ON IS AN INCREDIBLY SIMPLE
MEASURE SEEKING TO RENAME THE
TRANSGENDER WELLNESS IN EQUITY
FUND TO THE TGI WELLNESS IN
EQUITY FUND ALSO CREATE AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE OFFER INPUT
AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY WHILE
THEY ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM
BILLS ESTIMATED COST LESS THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND. A TO STAFF AND
CONVENE THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
AGAIN AS A MEMBER SANTIAGO
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK YOU
HELLO TO THE HEARING ROOM
SUPPORT. PHONE OPERATOR SUPPORT
ON TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE. HERE
IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. A
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM
NAY NONE OPPOSITION ONLINE.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE. IF
YOU'RE NOT POSITION OF TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. WE'RE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THIS BILL
IS OUT UP WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. THE.
IF WE COULD TAKE JUST ABOUT A
TWO OR THREE MINUTE- RECESS. WE
HAVE ONE BILL TO FINISH UP ON
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO PUBLIC.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA TAKE A- ADDING
VOTES ON TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WILL TAKE UP. BONTA VINCE FONG
GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I ON THE
CONSENT EDUARDO GARCIA.
OKAY WE'LL MOVE BACK TO. AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR BONTA OF
THAT BILL IS OUT ON THE B. ROLL
CALL WITH LEVINE VOTING NO WEBER
NOT VOTING. SO NOW WE'LL MOVE TO
WE'VE DISPENSED WITH OUR PUBLIC
HEARINGS FOR TODAY WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR. OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENT AS RELATES TO
BILLS THAT WERE NOT PRESENT AT.
TODAY OF THE RUN CONSENT OR
SUSPENSE WILL START HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL- AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT CRISTINA
GARCIA IN OPPOSITION. AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY NINE BLOOM IN
OPPOSITION AND AB TWENTY ELEVEN
WICKS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. A GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- CREAM GREASY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY SEVEN BLOOM I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN OVER AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR CONSIDERING OUR
CONCERNS. THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
AM MEMBERS ARE CASEY O'CONNOR
LED DIRECTOR FOR STATE TREASURER
FIONA MA JUST WANTED TO MENTION
OUR SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN BONTA.
WHICH IS THE COLLEGE ACCESS TAX
CREDIT FUND IS REIMBURSABLE SO
THERE'S NO COST TO THE STATE
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU. SEENU
OTHERS TO RESENT PUBLIC COMMENT
IN THE HEARING ROOM WILL TURN TO
THE PHONE LINES PUBLIC COMMENT
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON BILL. YOU HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. LINE ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WINE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MORNING CARE HOLDER NUMBERS
MY NAME'S CHRISTINE TRENTON
GREAT AND HELP HOUSING
CALIFORNIA CALLING AND SHAUN
SPLIT EIGHTY TWO FIVE ONE SEVEN
BONTA. NINE ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GREETINGS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
JASON BROOM TELCO- SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF IBEW LOCAL FIVE NINE
FIVE THE ALAMEDA COUNTY BUILDING
TRADES AS WELL AS A STATE
BUILDING TRADES. AND STANDING IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO RUNS. THANK
YOU. MY MODEL TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU MORNING MY NAME IS
MARK MOELLER AND ST BUILDING
TRAVÉS AND I'M OPPOSITION TO
BRICKS TWENTY ELEVEN. THANK YOU
. ONE ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN ONE FIFTY FIVE. HELLO
BETWEEN LONDON BEHALF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
AND STRONG SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN
OH FIVE IRWIN AND EIGHTY
SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA I THOUGHT EIGHTY
TWO SIX ONE SEVEN OFF OF HERE WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA DOCUMENTED
HIGHER EDUCATION COALITION AND
SHOCK THE WORLD AB TWO SIX FIVE
TWO. THANK YOU. NINE FORTY SEVEN
LINE IS OPEN FORTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING GARY. YES GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS OLD BY LOCAL TO WALL
MAKERS LOCAL FIVE FORTY NINE AT
FIVE FORTY NINE AM SUPPORT WITH
THE- JOIN IN THE BUILDING STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY ELEVEN. NINE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN NINE EIGHTY.
MISTER KERR THIS IS BOB NAYLOR
FOR FIELD SAID COMPANY. OWNED BY
HOWARD AHMANSON JUNIOR ORANGE
COUNTY- CALANTZOPOULOS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ELEVEN BY
WICKS. NINE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THIRTY ONE. THE MORNING
ISABELLA- BUT ON BEHALF OF- IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ELEVEN THE
END OF THE PROJECT CO SPONSORED
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE THANK
YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE TWENTY ONE. A
GOOD MORNING THIS IS RICHARD
PRYOR I AM THE CHIEF STRATEGY
OFFICER AT THE MISSION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN SAN
FRANCISCO CALLING HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIVE ONE SEVEN
MEDIA BONTA. WE'RE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE GIPHY PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE AND I VOTE FOR A B. TWO
FIVE ONE SEVEN. BECAUSE IT WAS
FULLY FUND STATE SUPPORT FOR
MORE CRADLE TO CAREER
ORGANIZATIONS THANK YOU. NINE
ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE SIXTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING SURE MEMBERS ARE NOT
SURE WHAT THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION- OUR BOND-
SPONSORED AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
ONE MULLIN IN ADDITION WAS A
POOR AB NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT-
THING AB TWENTY THIRTY FOUR
DONNELL AB TWENTY CENTRIFUGES
REYES AB TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
FOUR WEBER. AND AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY FOUR GIPSON THANK YOU.
LINE ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE ZERO FIVE. WARNING IF
YOUR CHAIR NUMBERS GREGORY
CLAIBORNE APPLE DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WANT TO PUT IT
AB TWENTY TWENTY NINE. IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY THREE
THIRTY WAY. OR AB TWENTY THREE
NINE. SPONSORED AB. TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN FIVE. FOUR EIGHTY TWO FIVE
NINETY SEVEN. FOUR EIGHTY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN YEAH THANKS AB TWENTY
FIFTY TWO BY THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. NINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE FIFTY EIGHT. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CALLED
MARINO WITH IRON WORKERS LOCAL
FORTY THIRTY THREE AND THAT
WE'RE STANDING WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES AND OPPOSING AB TWENTY
ELEVEN AWARE. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
OUTFIT. IF YOU INVOLUNTARY WITH
IBEW LOCAL THREE OR TWO THEY ARE
ALSO JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES AT OPPOSING AB TWENTY
ELEVEN AWAY. NINE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN EIGHTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ROBERT SMITH
WITH THE PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY
SIX IN STRONG OPPOSITION. TO
BUFFY WICKS A BILL TWENTY ELEVEN
THANK YOU STE. HI NINE ONE SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE SIXTY.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS CHRIS WITH SAKE WITH
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION WHERE
THE SPONSORS OF AB TWO THIRDS OR
TWO BY VIA PADILLA WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THE
BILL AND THINK THE
APPROPRIATIONS STAFFER
THOUGHTFUL AND THOROUGH ANALYSIS
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE SIXTY ONE
. GOOD MORNING HER MEMBERS JULIA
HOLE WITH THE PHYSICIAN OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY TWO AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN THIRTY
ONE THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIX
THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JAMES THOROUGH
ACTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO A. B. TWO ZERO ONE
ONE THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FIFTY CENT. HI
THIS IS JAMES MOSES WITH CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER WERE A
PROUD SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY ONE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKING IN SUPPORT THAT BILL
WE'RE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILLS TWENTY EIGHT ZERO
SIX RUBIO AND TWENTY ONE THIRTY
ONE MOLAR. THANK YOU FOR. NINE
ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE THIRTY FIVE. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS VANESSA
MOREAU- I AM CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB CHIU FIVE ONE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS OF SAN FRANCISCO
THE PRESYNAPTIC EIGHTY INCLUDE
ENOUGH FUNDING FOR THE EXISTING
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD. AND THEN
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY. URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES. FOR A. B. FIVE ONE SEVEN
BECAUSE OF WHAT POLICE STATE
SUPPORT OF MORE CREATIVE A PRE
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS ALLOW
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE COULD BENEFIT FROM ITS
SERVICES THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN FIFTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING THAT BEGINS
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL NUMBER TWELVE
STANDING WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO ZERO ONE ONE. NINE ONE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
FIFTY. YES GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
MORNING SEASON FOUR HUNDRED
TEAMSTERS LOCAL NINE EIGHTY SIX
AND WE ARE GOING TO THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY ELEVEN. NINE ONE SIX
THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
SIXTY FIVE. HELLO HOW ARE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE MIDDLE THAT THE
WITH THE HELP OF IRONWORKERS-
JOINING STATE BUILDING TADES IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY ELEVEN.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE OH NINE. HI
GOOD MORNING CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES OKAY THIS MANY PARA
MONTEREY SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL BUT THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES WERE OPPOSED AB TWO ZERO
ONE ONE THANK YOU. HI NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX A LINE IS OPEN ONE
SIXTY SIX. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE ACTUALLY CHOP ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
STARK RECORD OF EIGHTY TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY NINE ALSO ON AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT AM
STRONG SUPPORT. ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION WHO
IS ALSO A PROUD SPONSOR AND
FINALLY AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM IN
SUPPORT OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY EIGHT EE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS STEVEN BOOKER ON THE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
AFFAIRS LIAISON FOR IBEW LOCAL
SIX SEVENTEEN SAN MATTEO COUNTY
. I'M GOING TO STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF
AB TWO ZERO ONE ONE THANK YOU.
NINE ONE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE ZERO EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING THAT SHAREHOLDERS
MEMBERS MY NAME CHIFFON OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT PROGRAM
OPERATIONS WITH FTPS SAN DIEGO
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN. NINE ONE OLD I'M
SORRY YOUR MIND ONE OH EIGHT OH
NO I'M SORRY LINE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING BERNIE
GOLDBERG WITH THE LABORERS.
DISTRICT COUNCIL IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSING
A. B. TWO ZERO ONE ONE THANK YOU
. LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
CHRIS HOUSTON I'M OF IBEW LOCAL
NINE FIVE TWO HERE IN VENTURA
COUNTY AND I'M JOINING WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION OF. AB TWO ZERO ONE
ONE. NINE THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THIRTY TWO. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS HANNAH DAVIDSON ON
BEHALF OF THE HIDDEN VALLEY LAKE
COMMUNITY SERVICES DISTRICT WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TWENTY NINE. RESEARCH HAVE A
LOOK HERE YOUR LOCAL FIVE NINE
FIVE INDEPENDENT COUNTY BUILDING
CENTRIFUGES AND WE'RE STANDING
WITH THE STATE BUILDING CREEK
OPPOSITION AB. TWENTY ELEVEN
THANK YOU. MY SIX THREE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS ALL. ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. GEN NINE CAN I HELP GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS-
I'M CALLING THIS MORNING ON
BEHALF THAT THE DENTAL ASSISTING
ALLIANCE AND THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL HYGIENISTS ASSOCIATION
THE DENTAL ASSISTANTS AND
HYGIENISTS REMAIN OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX WE HAVE
SHARED AMENDMENTS WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR. THE DALLAS
AGAINST PLANET AS WELL OVERHAUL
TO THEIR PRACTICE BECAUSE THIS
FALL AND THEY- THE DENTAL
ASSISTING CAREER LADDER WOULD BE
BEST TO DRESS DURING THIS
DISCUSSION. SO WE ASK ABOUT
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING SURE MEMORY
BRIAN WEISS HER BEHALF OF
CYPRESS CREEK RENEWABLES. AB.
TWO ONE SIX TWENTY SIXTEEN TO
REMOVE WARD. FOR CREATING NEW
AND BETTER. PROGRAMS AFTER
PORTION IMPACT ANY REPAIRS THAT. MY ONE SEVEN ONE YEAR LINE IS
ALL ONE SEVENTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING HERALD IN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARGARET ATWOOD GRAHAM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE TANDEM
PARTNERS IN EARLY LEARNING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN WHERE IF YOU CAN'T THE
FEELING BECAUSE NOT FUNDING THE
MAYBE FIVE. AND ENCOURAGE THE
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL TO FULLY
FUND STATE SUPPORT FOR PROGRAMS
LIKE THAT FROM CRADLE. TO CAREER
SERVICES THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
. LINE ONE THIRTY FOR YOURLINE
IS OPEN ONE THIRTY FOUR. HI
THERE THE OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY ARE. SORRY ORANGE
COUNTY ONLY I BELIEVE YOURSELF
WHEN RIVERS LOCAL TO TWENTY
STANDING WITH THE STATE BUILDING
DRIVEN OPPOSING AB TWO ZERO ONE
ONE THANK YOU. NINE ONE SEVEN DE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE SEVENTY.
GOOD MORNING GRETCHEN THIS ON
BEHALF OF IBEW LOCAL FIVE SIX
NINE SAN DIEGO AND IMPERIAL
COUNTY STANDING WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY ELEVEN THANK YOU. LINE
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. HI THIS
IS TERRY TIA'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THIRTY AS WELL
AS. EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE EIGHTY TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FOUR OH TWO. NINE ONE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
EIGHTY. NINE ONE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE EIGHTY-
FIND ONE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN ONE SEVENTY SIX. HI MY
NAME IS AND THE STOCK. ARE YOU
CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FIRST LARGE FEELING
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWO FIVE
THREE. LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE EIGHTY ONE.
MISTER CHAIR COUNTERTERRORISM TO
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF A CO SPONSORED
BILL AB TWO ZERO THREE FOUR
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINE PLUS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE. EVERYONE WHO HAS
PARTICIPATED IN A PUBLIC COMMENT
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- FOR ADDITIONAL
OUT ON. VINCE FONG. IT'S FUN I.
EDUARDO GARCIA. FIVE THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.